[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
we have had three
technical failures but we've made it
happen and this is an improv episode i'm
very excited about it because my friend
chris reached out with many questions
about podcasting good questions he had
already read much of what i had written
he'd listened to several interviews and
this is intended to be an updated guide
to all things
podcasting the last time i wrote
anything at length about this i think
the tim ferriss show had about
60 or 65 million total downloads now
it's past 700 million
so the show has grown a lot has happened
technologies have i want to say
developed not always evolved as we may
end up covering but
chris why don't you take a moment to
tell people who you are we've known each
other now for at least
six years maybe closer to ten i can't
really even recall how we first met but
we have a mutual friend and kevin rose
and many other people
who are you chris
so hi everybody i'm chris uh chris
hutchins
i'm a bit of one of those crazy life
hacker optimizers take it to the extreme
sometimes and i host a podcast
hopefully a soon to be award-winning
podcast
called all the hacks where i document my
journey to upgrade my life money travel
all while spending less and saving more
outside of that i'm uh building new
products at wealthfront and before all
of this i've
started a few companies sold a few
companies worked in venture capital
investment banking management consulting
and and kind of traveled around the
world for eight months so a bit of a bit
of a you know seasoned set of random
things jack of all trades maybe master
of none and i'm excited to be here
well i am excited to
jam because i actually haven't spoken at
length in detail about the latest and
greatest or in some
cases the old and the tried and the true
that i don't think needs to change
but i want to underscore that you
really do
know what you're doing when it comes to
certain obsessive
deep dives that you've done
particularly i shouldn't say
particularly but including travel
and
points and not just
saving or cutting costs but improving
the immersive experiences that you have
in life and so you've traveled to
roughly 70 countries mostly for free on
points and there's much more to it how
many episodes
have you recorded and published so far
of your podcast just so people have some
context this is relatively new i think i
just released episode 19 when we're
recording this so it's been
it started in may it's september so only
you know four or five months
all right
so we'll
we'll come at this from many different
angles but where do you think it makes
sense
to start in preparation for this hoping
this would be sort of the one-stop
shopping or at least the jumping off
point for anyone who really wants
to
study
maybe not best practices but good
practices
within podcasting
uh where do you think it makes sense to
start
so there were two things that you've
done that i think really gave me a lot
of background and one was the post you
mentioned that you wrote in 2016
and then you did a you know maybe two
hour something interview with rolf potts
on his dv8 podcast and talked a lot
about this so
i thought maybe to kick it off i'll just
highlight some of my takeaways from
doing my homework and you know feel free
to say well that's wrong that's changed
but we can kind of run through what i
learned and then we can kind of run
through that same series of kind of
getting started picking gear finding
guests again and kind of dive deeper on
on what's changed and how it's evolved
and questions that maybe were left
unanswered in the original stuff let's
do it
perfect so
you know when it comes to getting
started this is something that you know
i like you took a while to decide to
start a podcast and you know one of the
pieces of advice that you gave that was
really valuable to me was you don't have
to commit forever i think it always
feels like a thing that you have to do
forever once you start it happens every
week forever and you know you can kind
of set a date and say let's do five
let's do 10 episodes and that's it and
we'll reevaluate so i think that's a
really important takeaway is that
knowing you don't have to commit forever
and the other big one is it's a it's a
lot more work than it seems and so you
said only do this if you do it for free
which really means like it's got to be
you it's got to be what format excites
you
the tone of voice the kinds of guests
the questions that are exciting to you
otherwise you'll get bored and the final
kind of getting started advice i took
away was look if you don't have an
audience don't be afraid right everyone
started with some lack of audience at
some point and plenty of people with
massive audiences have totally failed in
podcasting so
the quick way is you know just get a
couple episodes out there keep it simple
do something you love don't worry about
the business side and experiment and i
think that kind of sums up what everyone
needs to know in a very concise way
before getting started
let me add to that so i agree
with all of that and i want to add a
couple of
nuances or just additional comments
so it's helpful to bracket the minimum
and
then a check-in point
for
your commitment to podcasting in other
words you could say i'm only committing
to do it to
x or for y number of episodes i decided
to do six episodes to commit to six
episodes in the beginning because i
wanted to ensure that i could win even
if i failed what that meant was
what skills can i develop learn or
improve what relationships can i forge
or deepen
that will be of value to me even if i
stop podcasting
so
the minimum effective dose for that is
probably not one episode it's probably
not two episodes probably not three
episodes for me i thought yeah it's
probably somewhere between five and ten
let's just commit to doing six i don't
know exactly why i chose six
and the
way i could win even if i failed in that
case was by improving my ability to ask
questions and plan interviews because i
was already doing that in the course of
writing books when i did research when i
found experts these were all
transferable skills and then i would
also have an excuse to deepen
relationships with some of my close
friends because it's pretty creepy to do
hours and hours of internet sleuthing on
your friends otherwise but if you have
the pretext of an interview
you can actually learn a lot about
people like kevin rose our mutual friend
who is my first guest ever who shaped my
nuts really hard and it's pretty funny
to listen to now
it was less amusing at the time
so that's i think an aspect of the
picking of the minimum dose that's
important
doing something you love is ideal if you
can do something you love fantastic if
you don't know what it is that you love
or would love because if it's a new
medium you may have no idea at least do
something that is sustainable
don't do something for say six episodes
that you can't do for 500 episodes
that's my advice
and if you try to out this american life
this american life you're gonna get your
face ripped off there's a reason when
they
read the credits at the end that they
have staff like 20 or 30 people it is an
incredible amount of work
and
they work very hard for it to seem
seamless and maybe even improvised wow
it's so conversational they do this with
the team at gimlet as well you listen to
like oh they're just having a
conversation like no believe me they're
not just having a conversation
and
so sustainability
is super important and like you said
chris there's more involved than you
expect and you should ask yourself this
applies to podcasting it applies to many
other things if this cost twice as much
took twice as much time would i still do
it and if the answer is no
either don't do it or change the format
change the approach so that the answer
is yes and
podcasting is not the native element for
all people right so
if you think about
how people with large audiences have
built large audiences
in some cases they build them on youtube
and then that audience follows them to
new formats
in some cases
mine would be
such a case they build it through books
but books don't give you direct access
to
readers in the same way that podcasts do
not give you direct access to your
listeners
so i ported the popularity of the books
into building a popular blog the blog is
what gave me an audience that then
traveled in part at least to podcasting
so a lot of building a large audience if
that is one of your goals and by the way
i don't think that is a worthwhile goal
in and of itself i would ask why why why
why at least a few times
or so what
at the very least
then
you need to choose a game you can win
and
that requires some self-assessment but
for instance if you decide you should do
podcasting because everyone else is
doing podcasting
you are going to be
outlasted outsmarted out maneuvered by
people who are really really
enthusiastic about the medium about the
format they're just going to be better
and they're going to last longer
there's this
gigantic kind of elephant graveyard of
three episode podcasts
so if you're
likely to be a casualty do something
else pick a different medium and
because i
mentioned
it i think at the very head of the show
if i didn't i should have
we had a number of technical
difficulties in getting this show
started we had a number of false starts
we began sorry to throw you guys under
the bus but you kind of
failed us today zencaster had a number
of issues
then the plan was to jump to squad cast
but you have used riverside.fm
all of these platforms i have seen fail
none of them are perfect and
therefore on the technical side whether
you are in person or remote
the expression that i first learned from
friends in the military two is one and
one is none if you have a single point
of failure you are going to be [ __ ] at
some point you will have a disaster and
it will be a mess
always have backup options so in the
calendar invite
or in the email that was sent to chris
and also in my calendar
there are at least two backup options
and both of us are currently recording
local backup audio using quicktime audio
so
those are a few things that i wanted
to add
please continue chris
so i do want to talk about gear but i'll
ask one question before which is in 2017
you said yeah it's definitely not too
late to start a podcast
but you know that was a long time ago 24
of people had listened to a podcast now
it's closer to 60. there were a few
hundred thousand podcasts now there's
over 2 million you still think we're
early in the the days of podcasting and
there's lots of opportunity or is it too
crowded and people should consider new
mediums for content i think it's still
super early i think it's it's still
super super early there are some
indicators or
maybe proxies that you can use for that
uh the percentage of say terrestrial
radio or satellite radio advertising
dollars that have migrated to podcasting
still extremely low i don't know what
the percentage is but it's very
low i would anticipate just based on the
types of brands that you see represented
and you can look at other types of media
so based on that alone
i think we are very much in the early
days super super early days
and
that said we've seen a lot of changes
over the last handful of years if you
look at the charts say on
apple or elsewhere if you look at apple
the
sort of one-person shops or small team
shops like mine are fewer and fewer and
far
between
where let's just say when i got started
in
whenever it was 2014 i think maybe a
little bit earlier
you had
joe rogan way up at the top of course
you had nerdist you had marc maron you
had
a handful
of others who were constantly in the top
10 top 20 on what was then itunes
what you see now is professional outfits
you see companies you see organizations
wnyc
you see
pushkin which which i think does a
really nice job you see actual companies
you see also incumbents previous sort of
terrestrial incumbents who are now
investing dollars into podcasting so
there has never been more competition
but
the analogy i might use is
let's use startup investing something
that you and i are quite familiar with
so i had the very good luck of
starting to do angel investing in 2008.
now this was perfect timing because
there was a financial crisis which meant
all the fair weather
entrepreneurs founders
and investors kind of ran for the hills
and that left the die hards and the true
believers
which meant that the
playing field was very uncrowded and you
could actually find really really good
startups i believed all over the place
in 2008 2009 it was a great time to
invest
in
2015 or so i decided to exit stage left
not because there weren't great
companies there were great companies but
it was a lot harder the deal terms were
harder there was a huge influx of
capital from all over the place
including china things were getting
really weird
for me and i realized okay this just
went from single deck blackjack
where you could have a system as a solo
player as a team
to
multiple deck blackjack and i don't have
confidence using my own bankroll that i
can win in this environment so i took a
long break
similarly you just have to be better now
when i started in 2014 and if you had an
a
a an existing audience that would travel
with you you could be in the top
20 30 40 50
on
then itunes now apple with relative ease
and you can still do that if you have a
massive influx of subscribers over a
short period of time it could be a few
days could be a week but you'll fall off
it's simply harder now
so there there's all the more reason why
you should have confidence
that you're going to do this with some
degree
of dedication to the craft like
eucharist you're taking the study of the
craft and the practice and the
deliberate
training so to speak very seriously
and you have to have i think good
reasons for doing it and a good reason
could be i enjoy doing it great that's a
good enough reason you do not need to be
on the charts to have a quote-unquote
successful podcast but you have to ask
yourself
why am i starting a podcast why do i
want to start a podcast so let me ask
you that chris why did you want to start
podcast why did you decide to start a
podcast
i think two things happened at the same
time so one was i found myself
constantly
whether i was with a group of people i
knew or didn't know kind of telling
a story about a level of optimization
that you know in in the financial travel
world that most people
hadn't thought about and i thought man
i love telling that story to people
could i tell that story at more scale
because it seems like it's happening a
person at a time so that was a piece of
it and then the bigger piece was
i loved that game and i knew that the
only way i would get better at that game
and go deeper at that game was to learn
and there are people out there that know
much more about different types of ways
to upgrade life ways to optimize ways to
make more money or save more money or
invest better and if i had a you know i
was going to find those people and have
those conversations anyway because i was
but i knew that people loved hearing
those stories in small groups and i
thought if i had a platform where i
could have those conversations and share
them
people just like i would see at a dinner
table would enjoy listening to them at
you know in on a run at home driving in
the car and so i thought i'm going to do
this anyways i love doing it why not see
if other people really do want to listen
at scale and they did
do you still
feel like that is enough the psychic
gratification of
sharing what you would have done
otherwise because the reality is
it is kind of what you would have done
otherwise but the setup and the tech and
the microphones and the post-production
and everything else involved adds a
layer of
labor and complexity
right so what
on top of that if anything there doesn't
need to be anything extra
but how is your thinking changed on what
makes it worthwhile to continue or not
well what's interesting is let's take an
episode i did with uh writer morgan
housel and it was all about the
psychology of money
i'd read the book i'd been fascinated by
it i had questions i wanted to ask
morgan
i could probably just reach out and say
hey i'm just a person and i want to
learn more about what you wrote can we
talk
but
i'm i'm guessing i would have had better
success which i did saying hey i have
this podcast i want to talk i want to
ask those questions and share that with
my audience and so
having the podcast lets you level up
i believe the people you can have those
conversations with because there's a
reason it gives a reason to to do that
and then as the audience grows it gives
a second reason so one is
you know it's not you could just reach
out and say can we do a phone call but
you know there's at least a reason and
then as the audience grows there's more
and that i think is worth the trade-off
of the amount of work you have to put
into it but
you know you mentioned gear there's a
world where and i believe you can buy
you know a microphone for under a
hundred dollars and use a pair of
headphones you already own and keep it
pretty simple and i think to your your
original post uh and what we talked
about earlier
the more simple you make it the easier
it will be to keep going and the more
authentic it will be which you know you
may think you want to say something
because it's what the audience wants to
hear and there's this weird thing where
it's actually just ask what you want and
most people are more engaged by your
engagement with a conversation than if
you ask a question they want to hear but
you're bored having that conversation
yeah absolutely and and just to give
people a sense
right now i'm using what i
use more or less all of the time
for remote recording and i remotely
record even pre-covered probably
80 90
of my interviews it allows you to get
better guests by the way
generally speaking unless you're the
undisputed king of podcasts like joe
rogan then you can insist on
in-person visits but very few podcasters
have that leverage and you will
sacrifice some guests by having those
conditions
so i do everything remotely it makes my
life easier as well i'm in a farmhouse
right now i've recorded dozens of
podcasts here
and i have a logitech brio camera which
i do not use all the time i very
frequently do audio only we could talk
about why i don't do more video
i have
an audio technica atr 2100 x one of the
more recent it might be a 2500 but and
you have that exact microphone in front
of you
this is probably what would you say an
80 80 80 to 100 microphone that connects
to my macbook pro and then i'm using
airpods
for in-ear listening
that's it that is the sum total of
hardware that i am using and we're
currently recording on
riverside.fm which you use i typically
use zencaster and squadcast
but all of these things break so have
backup and if this didn't work
i also have
a
conference line with no pin
that can be set to record so if my
computer broke
i could call chris on my cell phone
and we could record the conversation i
have backups upon backups upon backups
and trust me at some point you're gonna
need it
is there a point at which you would just
reschedule
instead of or or how do you think about
that you know the quality of a
conference bridge being maybe not worth
doing now and postponing to when your
computer worked again
i will
reschedule if
the connection is really bad
or if the audio on the opposite end is
very poor
and
to try to minimize the likelihood of the
audio being poor on the other end
we ship every guest a microphone
unless they already have a really
polished setup we will
use amazon prime to buy an audio
technica 2100 mic and ship it to them
and
it's very easy to do it's 80 to 100
bucks
and that may not make any sense in the
beginning or be feasible in the
beginning but right now for the type of
operation that i run and very quickly
the cost of rescheduling is more to me
than 80 to 100 dollars
however you can have a great mic and a
really terrible room so if someone's in
a room with lots of metal lots of glass
you could have a very
bouncy room even with a decent mic
so there are other technical tricks
that are not really tricks but
you could have a mediocre mic in a room
with lots of carpet and drapes and
you're going to probably have better
sound than a really nice mic in
some highly modern metallic glass
bouncy room if you end up in that type
of environment there are tricks you can
use like putting pillows in the corners
of the room that's one i learned from
edward norton actually he was in a
really bouncy room and he said hold on i
know how to fix this and he fixed it i
was like wow that's genius
so you do get better at these things
over time
but i very rarely reschedule unless one
of us is sick
or the sound quality is absolutely
abysmal
but
a bridge line recording is not going to
give you carnegie hall
sort of symphony quality
fidelity
but nobody really cares is what i've
realized
i don't use equalizers i don't use any
of these external devices
that one might think are necessary yes
they can improve quality sometimes
but
as morgan spurlock said to me on
this podcast
once you get fancy fancy gets broken
and i prefer to have the fewest number
of moving pieces possible when i record
in person just to cover that
i use the zoom h6
recording device
with xlr cables and
generally sm58 stage microphones which
are sure microphones they're the oldest
microphones you can imagine yes so you
have the h6 you could take the sm58 mic
and probably throw it against a brick
wall and it would be fine that's my
guess
and i can throw all of that gear into a
backpack i can travel with my entire
podcast studio so to speak it's been
good enough for
between 600 and 700 episodes and i don't
have any plans to change
so that is the gear
yeah i use a similar setup and i would
say
i don't know if you you know a specific
one you could go listen to the episodes
i've done and only and one of them
someone had no headphones no microphone
we were just using a macbook
and i i'd be shocked if someone could
actually that isn't an audio engineer
could go back and pick out which one it
is yeah pro tip that we ended up using
earlier in this conversation which i
picked up from from kevin rose actually
who has a lot of experience with this
kind of thing
is if you're doing a remote recording
and you ask someone to check their
source to make sure the inputs and
outputs are set properly they might say
my mic is selected
but if it sounds funny to you ask them
to tap the mic if they tap the mic and
you don't hear that
right that
that kind of punchy
tapping sound then it means it is not
selected it's probably their headset or
the built-in microphone on the laptop so
that's an easy way to test to see if the
proper external mic
is selected all right
chris what what else should we cover
so i think we covered gear a lot
one thing you mentioned was video early
on your advice to people was
don't use video it makes it easier for
guests you can look at your notes
you said that's evolved a little bit
we're recording video today
how how do you think about that
differently now or or do you think about
it differently in a way that wouldn't
apply to someone else
i record
video now if someone wants to record and
if i think it will improve
the rapport in some fashion
i still frequently record without video
because i like to have
lots of notes i do quite a bit of
homework my team does quite a bit of
homework for each guest
and i like to have my notes in front of
me and it sometimes can be very
distracting if you're having a
conversation with someone on video and
you're looking off screen like rain man
i also like the ability to
set and i always set both the laptop and
my iphone to do not disturb because you
might just receive a facetime audio call
and that can mess up your interview it
does happen i've seen it i've
experienced it it's not fun so do not
disturb do not disturb but with do not
disturb on my iphone if i'm not using
video you could also take yourself off
video
temporarily to do this or you could tell
the guest in advance that if you check
your iphone you're not checking email
you're googling something what will
sometimes happen is a guest will say oh
well there's a book by so and so it's
called this i can't remember the author
name
you can look that up or they will say
there are
three people who are really good at x y
and z they'll name two and then they'll
say the second person i think their
first name is laura or brian
and you can look it up so you don't have
to deal with it in post-production or
put in the show notes you can look it up
on an iphone and no one who is listening
will hear you tap the iphone but they
will very often hear you tap a laptop
so i use my phone in that way now you
could have
a production assistant or producer or an
engineer or someone like
that who would do this for you which is
what joe rogan does but
i i don't do that i have a smaller team
by the way it works spectacularly well
now speaking of joe so joe rogan is
fluent in video
he is
absolutely adept and expert
and comfortable being
in front of the cameras and making
really good use of cameras i think one
of the reasons
not the only reason but one of the major
reasons that joe has become as big as he
has is his use of youtube i don't know
if it's still the second largest search
engine in the world but it is a an
enormous
traffic driver
particularly if you take not just your
long-form videos
and put them online but create clips as
he has through jr eclipse and so on
and
if you are bringing on guests who are
going to be capitalizing on news or who
are part of the news themselves
then people will be searching for
these temporally relevant topics whether
it's someone who got fired someone who
got in trouble someone who made a big
decision a ceo who just found themselves
in the news
if you do that you can drive a lot of
traffic i
want to
produce
for the most part evergreen episodes
that will have very fat tails they get
listened to for years and years and
years and don't lose their relevance
that's important
to me
and i don't want to immerse myself in
the news any more than absolutely
necessary so i don't do that i also
don't think that i am as good on video
as joe right he has a studio he has a
visually interesting environment he is
funny he's a comedian he's an
entertainer very smart entertainer but
he's a very
very very skilled entertainer and it
makes sense
and they have just more production
capacity they've invested more in making
that a core component of what they do i
just am not interested enough
could i make my show bigger would it be
bigger if i tried to do all that i think
it would be
but this is an example of knowing
where you are strong knowing where you
are perhaps not as strong
and also asking yourself why am i doing
this
does my show does the tim ferriss show
need to be two times bigger three times
bigger ten times bigger
i can't come up with a really compelling
reason for why that's the case would i
like it to grow yes
do i need it to grow even if it involves
doing things i dislike no that would be
so stupid it would be so stupid and i've
made that mistake but you're at a scale
you're at a scale now that you know you
can your show can afford the
you know person to help you prep for
guests and that kind of stuff what do
you think about people earlier i'm at a
place right now where
i've recorded the video of a lot of my
interviews but i haven't done anything
with it yet and i know it could help
grow the show and the show couldn't
monetize to support it so growth is kind
of a factor right it plays into the
longevity of the show because
it takes time and you know yes i would
do it for free but you know i also you
know you got bills you got you know
people have things they have to do so if
they want to do it more it does need to
grow
do you think it would be different if
your show was smaller and it couldn't
afford all those things yeah well let me
let me dig into a bunch of
pieces of what you just said and ask
some follow-up questions so
would it would my operation how
different would my operation look if i
were just getting started well let's
rewind the clock i can tell you exactly
what i did when i got started i wanted
to know how to do everything
and that's part of my nature but it's
also because i wanted to try to create
as elegant an operation as possible for
myself elegant is not the same
does not have the same definition it
doesn't have the same puzzle pieces for
everyone so i not only recorded
everything myself i edited everything
myself i published everything myself i
uploaded the file to hosting services
and so on and so forth right
so in the very early days i didn't have
someone to help me with research
i still
appreciate and value having someone to
help me with research but if for
whatever reason that weren't possible
i have full confidence that i could do
that myself
but let's let's take a look
at something you said and that is
and it comes back to this question i had
earlier of
is the podcast still worth it right to
get to episode 50 episode 100 for you
what does the podcast need to be
for
it to be worth doing well worth doing
easily worth doing right so you said
we got bills
[ __ ] got bills to pay gotta keep this
gotta keep this ship afloat now
i don't have a perfect window into all
of your personal finances but i have on
some reasonable authority sufficient
belief that you could probably cover
your podcasting bills and i know the
costs involved with a lot of podcasting
without having to monetize the show
right so
it would be nice to monetize the show
but you could
make that money in some other way right
so
let me jump to a point about monetizing
that i mentioned i believe in that 2016
article and probably again with ralph
potts on deviate
and that is in the beginning i did not
focus on
monetization now it's very easy for
someone to say well you already had
money therefore
your advice doesn't apply to me your
experience doesn't apply to me i would
discourage you from looking at it with
that lens you meaning listener because
you can learn something from
everyone and even if their decisions are
not the decisions you would make it's
helpful to learn how more experienced
people have thought about it right so
the the way they go about making
decisions
i
felt especially since i was doing the
editing and so on myself
that any focus on
monetization
even if you think it's only going to be
five percent of your time
and we can come back to sort of
preoccupation versus active time on
something
i didn't want anything to distract from
my
focus on improving my ability to prepare
an interview and edit i wanted to focus
on the craft the product and that was it
right that was that that was to be my my
real soul
focus which the editing helps with by
the way the editing forces you to listen
to everything really carefully
not saying everyone should edit their
own stuff i no longer edit my own
episodes but we do get everything
transcribed and we go through and we
look at ways to clean up and tighten and
possibly cut or rearrange we do that
with a lot of episodes not all of them
so i didn't focus on or pay attention to
monetizing for the first
i don't know i'd have to go back and
somebody could probably confirm this but
who knows 60 70 100 episodes i'm not
even sure
by that point the
downloads were such that i had a
broader spectrum of possible sponsors to
choose from and
that felt better to me than taking
whatever came over the transom early
however
i believe chris one of your questions
that you had from me was
along the lines of should i say no to
things that come over the transom
so let me
take a step back and i will answer that
but how are you thinking about
monetizing because it is it is very easy
and i'm not saying this to you chris
specifically but for people to get
uh pulled
away
from the creative by the siren song
the mesmerizing nature of monetizing
because every time you go on twitter
there's something trending that's like
here's how much top influencers get paid
on instagram and you're like what
hundred thousand dollars a post that's
[ __ ] crazy i want to make a hundred
thousand dollars a post and then oh boy
then you're lost
right so how are you thinking about
monetizing right now and i should say
chris is smart you're smart with your
money you are not you are very
deliberate and you've done a lot of
homework you're a student of personal
finance
and money but how are you thinking about
monetizing and what to do or not do with
it i took a similar approach to you and
it was maybe for a slightly if your
reason was to hone the craft mine was to
prove out the longevity so
going to spend any time monetizing your
podcast before you realize this is
something that i could do for a long
time which you will never know until you
do it for at least yeah you did six for
me it probably took five or ten maybe
ten episodes
until that point it was a complete it
would have been a complete waste of time
to think about monetizing because i
didn't know if i was going to do this
and the amount of money you're going to
make on a 10 episode podcast is almost
nothing so
i said let's make sure this is something
i could do forever before i think about
it
then i thought okay let's also make sure
that the amount of money it would
generate is even worth the effort
sponsors have reached out and said oh we
want to advertise on two episodes it's
like okay but like if i'm gonna sell you
know two sponsors on a show two episodes
at a time you know we're talking 50
calls a year
to sponsors and that's just the ones
that say yes so maybe you're you're
doing you know 200 calls to try to line
sponsors up that just seemed like a
distraction for how much it would make
so i had a similar kind of thought which
is get to a point in time where the
amount of money you'd make for the
amount of work it would take to bring
that money in is worth it
and
and the only deviation from that was
when people called outreach and say hey
can we just do this and it's like well
now it's no longer work but even then
i've since decided to say no not because
i think it would ruin the show just
because
i have a list of things that i
prioritize and for me it's researching
making the content great and finding the
people to bring on and if i spend time
on anything else it takes away from that
and that is not yet on autopilot and i
think ultimately that's all that really
matters like your show's not gonna be
good if it's not something people enjoy
listening to which is usually a factor
of who's talking and how much those
people have thought about what they're
gonna say or or at least prepared to
have a good conversation
yeah
yeah i i think that makes a whole lot of
sense couple of thoughts also on
monetizing figure out
figure out what
would be amazing
from a monetizing perspective and i'm
very deliberately not saying
sponsorship or advertising perspective
because there are
many different ways to convert a podcast
into
i shouldn't say convert
is a side effect of doing an awesome
podcast to produce income
right you could be let's just say you
are a high priced consultant
and
you don't have any advertising but you
generate
clients
from the podcast
that would be a somewhat straightforward
example
you could have
as many people do especially in the
early days affiliate relationships very
often the most lucrative of which are
going to be with certain types of
products right domain services hosting
etc they have a very high
stickiness
with their
customers high level of stickiness low
churn rate which means
high lifetime value they're willing to
pay you quite a bit up front
but is that what you want are those the
products services etc that you want
to be
endorsing
maybe maybe not
there are
many different ways to approach this
many different ways to generate
income perhaps you have a newsletter
that is a paid newsletter and
people sign up for that perhaps you have
a different version of the podcast or
you have a membership
of some sort outside of newsletters
maybe people pay for the show notes i
mean these are all real examples that
i've seen
for myself i decided that sponsorship
was the easiest i've done some
experiments with membership and they all
just entailed
more headache for me and
i felt ultimately less value all around
than
sponsorships assuming
in my case that i am using or testing
everything personally that is where
the sponsorships are somewhat time
consuming for me
but i don't i don't mind it because i
actually use like if you walk down my
house you would recognize all sorts of
stuff from my sponsors
and i don't just have them because
they're sponsors like i have them
because they are good products or
services
and
let me give a couple of examples of
questioning
best practices or standard operating
procedure with
sponsors
and
this may help people to simplify their
approach so i did not ask myself
how can i make as much money
with sponsors through the podcast
because there are no constraints on that
you're not applying
constraints in such a way to ensure that
your life does not become a miserable
existence of just being a pinata for
every ask and request of
dozens of sponsors right as it might be
in the example that you gave right that
could be a huge pain in the ass
so what constraints could you apply to
ensure that it does not become a monster
you have to feed or a huge distraction
a very simple constraint that i applied
was
a we're going to have our own insertion
order
document that is going to be
non-negotiable
and everyone is going to pre-pay for
their spots we will not have any terms
we're not going to have accounts
receivable we're not going to chase
people for payment everybody is going to
pay up front
and
what do you think the response was from
sponsors initially the response was
what the [ __ ] are you talking about we
get terms from everyone that's how this
is done
and i said that's fine
we don't have to work together this is
just what allows me and my tiny team to
remain sane
so
if it's not worth it it's not worth it i
totally understand
let me get back to work and make the
podcast so good that's there will be at
least a few sponsors who are going to
say you know what [ __ ] it we will pay
you up front
and
that
is something we have stuck to and i
cannot tell you how much that has
simplified
our lives and our operations
it also
acts as a litmus test for commitment
from sponsors
because as you noted
right to fill
let's just say in your case right
50 different sponsors at two spots a
piece if you have a high churn rate
meaning a lot of those people take two
episodes and then split and never come
back you're just gonna have to do that
again
next year that's exhausting right so i
wanna make sure there's a high level of
commitment
but there's also a high level of vetting
on my side
therefore a high probability that the
product
and the company will do really really
well in the podcast because i don't want
them to do two or three spots
and we do insist on a test of multiple
spots i'm not sure if it's two right now
it might be three and my podcast is
expensive very very very expensive i
mean it's a premium podcast
i want them to spend
millions of dollars on the podcast over
a long period of time
so everything is geared towards that
because it's it just simplifies
everything for everyone but the point i
wanted to make is
question best practices and if you are
not in a position to question best
practices
your product isn't good enough or you
don't have enough leverage for some
reason and you should take a very close
look at those reasons but it doesn't
hurt to ask for instance
what does every almost 99
of authors out there do
they publish a book in hardcover six to
nine months later the book comes out in
paperback and they hit the
press junket
once again and they go on tour to
announce
the launch of paperback
none of my books have ever gone to
paperback
why is that tim ferriss i'll tell you
it's because and the numbers vary but
not by that much
let's say that you're getting a 12
royalty
on your hardcover book
paperback royalty is probably going to
be
percent six and a half percent
so
broadly speaking paperback royalties are
uh you will you'll get paid
50 of what you're currently earning per
book by going to paperback
what does that mean that means you have
to sell twice as many books to make the
same amount of money
i'm skipping over some specifics here
but
more or less you have to sell twice as
many books to make what you are making
right now
what is the benefit to the reader of
this well we live in a world with audio
with kindle
and the benefit to the customer we also
have libraries where you can get
e-format for free oftentimes and
actually i learned of a very cool i
think it was a chrome extension on your
podcast in fact about this
the benefit to the consumer used to be
they could save whatever it might be
five dollars on cover price
with amazon which is generally selling
it almost i mean often close to
wholesale prices
that benefit just no longer exists so
for a marginal to non-existent benefit
to the end reader you are going to
voluntarily cut your royalties in half
which means you have to sell twice as
many books to earn the same amount per
year
that made no sense to me so i've never
done it
and
to their credit my publishers early on
were open to
this
logic for staying in hardcover and it
worked out really really well i did not
have a lot of leverage in the beginning
right i did not have
tim ferriss and marky lights as people
or some people perceive it today i
simply laid out the logic right so
really question what you have to do
because sometimes those best practices
make no sense whatsoever
yeah i think when you're yeah go ahead
no no go for it
lead us dear shepherd where should we go
next yeah i mean we've talked about
getting ready and all of that
but i'm curious i think the bulk of what
goes into podcasting is finding guests
prepping for the conversation and having
the conversation
and
i'll i'll tell everyone
even if you don't have a podcast
thinking about how to find interesting
people and to have a better more
informative exciting conversation is
probably valuable just in life and i
mean you said the reason you got started
and and if you never continued you will
have at least learned the skill that was
really valuable so i'll start with
finding people
when you first wrote your original post
there wasn't that much about finding
people uh you know look for people
you're interested in
the one thing that you said maybe not in
that post that i i thought was really
interesting was
don't put as much value as you think on
how big of a name they are
that that maybe half of your top
episodes are people that your listeners
had never heard of before and so it just
keeps coming back to
content is really really important
and people like good content more than
they like bad content with a fancy name
and i can i can attest to some of the
episodes where i thought people had the
smallest names that no one had ever
heard of have far outperformed
conversations i've had with like ramit
sethi who you know
we had a great conversation and and lots
of people know his name and
that that is something that i don't
think i thought going in would ever be
true
yes
why yes uh let's let's jump in so
this comes back to the
initial question of why do you want to
do a podcast
and
maybe it should be framed differently
right what is so compelling about this
that you're going to want to do a
hundred episodes of this podcast maybe
that's the question right like what is
so compelling about this that you will
be so thrilled
about doing 100 episodes of this podcast
that you would pay
not get paid but you would pay to do
this podcast
chances are
the answer is not
banging your head against a wall
trying to get through a phalanx of
publicists and lawyers and managers
and getting
the runaround from like hollywood
entourage for a year to get a guest
chances are you wouldn't pay to do that
if you chase famous people you are going
to do that
just to be clear
so maybe you should focus on doing
something
that really satisfies you and maybe in
some niche god knows where
some way somehow it's so [ __ ] good
that like a hundred people who might
know famous people are like wow this is
really smart right that's not guaranteed
but it's a possibility
so
for me the answer is
follow your interests
and make it easy in the beginning so in
the first i want to say
5 to 10 maybe 20 or 30 episodes
i
only interviewed people i knew quite
well
because i didn't need the nerves
of interviewing a stranger
to add to what was already somewhat
challenging does that make sense
and i remember i think it was ed catmull
the former president pixar who was the
first person i'd
ever interviewed who i hadn't had a
conversation with prior to the actual
interview
and
it was nerve-racking ended up being a
really fun interview but
it was very stressful for me
why i couldn't really pinpoint because i
talked to strangers all the time
and that's certainly true with the books
but
it felt different so make it
as easy as possible in the beginning
stack the deck so that you can win in
the beginning and for me that meant
doing it with friends
in terms of finding
guests
there are as many ways as you could
imagine and probably more than you could
imagine
but
the the focus of the show will direct
how you search
right so in my case
the tim ferriss show
has always been about world-class
performers in different disciplines and
trying to tease out the habits routines
favorite books etc that make them tick
or that they think might contribute to
making them good at what they do
frameworks
decisions
thought process all of that
uh turns out that's very very broad
right so i have some people on the
docket like there's a i think it's a
violin
assessor like evaluator
like someone who assesses and
rehabilitates you know multi-million
dollar
violence
i can tell you with with great
confidence that that does not have a
large
built-in audience
but
it's interesting to me and
i also think about which guests
will care enough to bring their a game
it doesn't matter how famous your guest
is it doesn't matter how good your guest
is if they don't bring their a game
right so
chris one of the things you asked me
if i'd be willing to do is listen to a
few episodes your podcast and provide
feedback
and the first episode i listened to is
actually the first episode you published
which i learned later was the fifth that
you'd recorded which is smart
on
on pro travel hacks with is it lee rowan
is that how you say the last name yeah
rowan and lee
is amazing lee is like sam harris he he
if he didn't have a teleprompter or
something that man speaks in finished
prose it's [ __ ] ridiculous right so
so lee is one of those guests
who clearly brought his a-game
and
i thought you did a very good job in the
interview and it's an area where you
have a lot of domain expertise but
honestly
you could have been making like zoo
animal noises and he could have just run
and it would have been a incredible
interview slash monologue do you know
what i mean if you were just like i'm
going to give you words
that i pull out of this hat and i want
you to riff for five minutes and you're
like uh arthropod
tax optimization uh grizzly bears like
i'm sure it would have been a really
fascinating conversation because lee is
just that good you know what i mean
there are those guests esther perrell is
one who comes to mind immediately hugh
jackman was was like that for me
there are many guests including those
you wouldn't
recognize
who are going to be really really really
good
and
so a big part of
guest selection is also
improving as an interviewer in quotation
marks
ultimately it is very hard to fix a bad
guest it does not matter how good you
are as an interviewer
the only fix that i have found is if i
generally budget 90 to 120 minutes for
an interview i'll usually say 90.
if i get 30 minutes in and i'm like oh
my god this is a stillborn like this is
a mess
this is we're not getting anywhere which
by the way can happen with people who
are very very very good
conversationalists but as soon as you
hit record once it's an interview and
not a conversation overwhelmed at dinner
they get really stilted and weird and
can't be themselves that happens quite
often
then i will talk more
this doesn't work for everyone it won't
work for everyone but generally i'm
going to come into the interview having
done a lot of homework i'll have some
domain familiarity if not expertise
and i will then ask a question where i
can reciprocate and give examples or buy
time by talking about something else
and in doing so
i will extend the time we might record
for two to two and a half hours
and
then we can cut that down
to say 30 to 60 minutes it will probably
include a lot of me
and the downside to that is people will
be like wow this guy really likes to
hear himself talk and it's like no i
just saved this interview
and
at the end of the day there will be some
actionable
takeaways within that interview right so
that's one way to save it
i will only try to save an interview
like that if someone is at least trying
and they have done the prep work so
when i talk to people or i should say
prior to ever interviewing people will
have a list of
commonly asked rapid fire questions
which i have right here
people will recognize a lot of them from
tribe of mentors
and other places but there are certain
questions i ask a lot like the
metaphorical billboard question favorite
failures etc there's certain questions i
ask frequently i send this to people in
advance
i generally don't send other questions
in advance
and i always
talk to people beforehand for five to
ten minutes before recording to loosen
them up
this is assuming they're not somebody
who's gotta publish this cracking the
whip on my face
so assuming they have a little bit of
slack in the system we'll talk in the
beginning i will first say
you like all of my guests have final cut
you can see
you can see a transcript beforehand you
can listen to the audio any edits you
want to make we can make this is not a
show about gotchas
so number one there's that and i will
say i've been screwed by journalists
before i've been had my trust betrayed
i've had things cherry-picked i've been
misquoted
it sucks
i'm not going to do that and you have
final cut
which by the way is what inside the
actors studio always did
and what you might have seen on tv for
those episodes 45 minutes an hour was
actually several hours of recording so
they would cut down substantially so
i'll do that first and in the say warm
up calisthenics
i will always ask someone what would
make this interview a home run when you
look back three six months from now
what would make this an absolute home
run where when people ask you what what
are your favorite two or three
interviews this is one of those two or
three
and people are always
almost always surprised when i ask that
because it's it's never asked
and
and i'll tell them because that can
inform how i try
to steer the conversation it will also
inform how we promote the episode
so
let me know if you have an answer and if
not if you have an answer later we can
try to customize things
i will also ask them is there anything
you absolutely don't want to talk about
or something that you're really sick of
talking about that you just don't want
to rehash
i will ask that
and by the time you ask these questions
it
or these types of questions a someone is
warmed up a little bit
b
they will think to themselves okay wow
this guy's this guy's really put some
thought into this is aware that i'm
coming into this with certain goals
and hopes or fears
and
this is not his first rodeo
and what i'll also then tell people is
you know
we can always cut things later but we
can't
put interesting things in so
feel free to curse be yourself like let
it all hang out we can always cut things
later but we can't put it in we can't
put the fun in
so
go crazy and we can always cut i would
say out of
whatever it is now six to seven hundred
episodes
less than three percent of the guests
ever ask to see the audio or transcript
it's very uncommon
but
i will take notes as we talk
and if someone say
mention something like a lawsuit which
might be
legally complicated for them it work
broadcast to millions of people or just
made public to honestly an audience of
100 people
or if they mention say details about
their family or where they live or they
say let me give out my email address i
will flag all of those things and i will
talk to them afterwards and say do you
want to keep this in are you sure you
want to keep this in i would suggest you
cut this
dot
to look out for them
also
and then my team will also listen to
things and review transcripts to try to
identify other things that should be cut
twitter is an excellent way to source
guests to come back to that question you
asked so long ago
twitter is an excellent way to find
guests although part of my feedback to
you on your podcast
is you mentioned twitter a lot and
twitter is a very
even though it's expanded a lot and i'm
sure it rankles twitter to death that
donald trump kind of saved twitter
how funny is that
it's still a very tech centric
environment
and so i would suggest to you that
you
drive people to the website and
preferably some type of newsletter so
that you have
the ability to to communicate directly
with your listeners podcasting is still
largely a black box
it's very difficult to get good
analytics this is also why it's very
difficult for me to give growth advice
because it's very difficult to
confirm attribution for different types
of organic or paid acquisition or pr
it's incredibly difficult we can talk
about growth i'm happy to talk about it
but the reason twitter works
specifically
for
guest recruitment
is
probably similar to how you could use
other platforms but my other platforms
are
completely deluged for instance maybe
you could use instagram dms for this but
because
i'm flooded by dms and anyone apparently
can send me a dm on instagram i can't
use it it is there's too much
noise not enough signal so it's it's an
unusable tool for me but on twitter
if you follow someone and then you like
something of theirs and then you retweet
and it's a lot easier if you have a
verified account of course
to get someone's attention but if you
follow them like something retweet
something
maybe reply to something of theirs and
kind of do it all at once so that you
occupy more of their timeline if they're
looking at replies and things like this
if they follow you you can dm them
and
if you dm them and connect with them you
can do so without having any
of their contact information
you don't have their email address you
don't have their phone number if they
dislike you they can block you
in other words
they don't have the same fear factor
associated with you having a direct line
to them in any fashion so for tribe of
mentors as an example the book
there were 100 maybe 120 people who
answered many of the
common questions from the podcast and
the way i connected with ben stiller and
dozens of the larger celebrities better
known figures was through twitter that
is how i made contact with them it is
also a very good way to make contact
with well-known people or
even if they're not well known difficult
to reach people
and to circumvent around their multiple
layers of entourage
because if you email an agent or a
manager
just get ready for the merry-go-round of
[ __ ] to start and there are some
great agents and managers out there i
don't want to imply that there aren't
but
if you're dealing with anything related
to hollywood nine times out of ten you
are just going to get this incredible
run around dance that can last forever
uh there are some incredibly talented
and hardworking and great agents and
managers so again not to malign all of
those
people in those categories
but you run the risk of an incredible
amount of hurry up and wait that can
last
years
even at this point for me by the way uh
that is true do you think if you had
their email you would use it over
twitter or is it you think twitter is a
better medium it might be better okay it
may be less crowded it depends entirely
on how
many people they follow
i will say
that
as someone who gets an incredible amount
of
[ __ ] sent to me
from one
through one means or another
that
if i have channels
that are intended for people to get in
touch with me and they disregard those
channels and think they're clever by
barraging me somehow
they're immediately blacklisted and most
people if they do get a random email
from you
what i would suggest if you're gonna
take that approach
that you indicate in the email how you
got their email address
i will i will no one on my team will
ever reply to someone who called emails
or if they try to get hold on like
phones or anything like that immediate
blacklist
but
maybe via email if they reach out if
they don't indicate how they found the
email no response like they need to they
need to clarify that first so if they
have channels for getting in touch with
them i would suggest that first
unless they're the their agency
well you know there there are cases
where
agencies it's not that you shouldn't
reach out here's what i would say
it's not that you can't and should never
reach out to an agent or a pr
agency or
a
manager to try to
reach
say a celebrity
or someone who's well known
it's that you should expect that to take
a lot of time
and an alternative or a compliment to
that would be
twitter with all of the time
and this is true actually for a lot of
optimizing in general
for me uh even though there there's
i i do i am fascinated by sort of
and we should we can talk about what
kind of what optimize means right
optimize for what is a good question
when thinking about a lot of these
things but
if i think about the number of pod
casters or would-be podcasters who ask
me about guest recruitment
and they don't need my help
to get 90
of the people out there
so really the question is how do i get
guests who are hard to reach
that's the question
if they completely avoided
guests who are hard to reach and just
focused on [ __ ] recording another 10
episodes
in the same amount of time the same
number of hours that they're going to
blow trying to get you know oprah on
their podcast
god bless oprah i wish i could have her
on my podcast i don't think it's going
to happen
i think they would be much further ahead
at the end of the day
i'll say two things about that first
episode i did with lee
one lee had never been on another
podcast so you know lee is not a
celebrity name that i think anyone knows
and that podcast that first episode has
had
two and a half times more downloads than
every other episode yeah so
it's content way over the name
and the other thing just because i
thought it was a funny example of
technology failing so in that episode we
we actually recorded in person we used a
zoom
and
we had a bad sd card no backup
and so
that episode was actually
three days later re-recording the
episodes it was a little different
than the original but i will say going
into that i had this huge fear that
you'll never be able to recreate a good
episode if you have to
and i'm not saying i would ever
encourage it but that fear was kind of
busted so i would rather have had the
backup of the original because it's hard
to try to to keep it going but
if you have to it it's not always a bad
outcome not always bad outcome so i
should actually modify my gear
recommendation and say that i also have
redundancy
in person so i have the h6 i've got that
usually i'll have another h6
sitting out and recording
but without the
the xlr so it'll be sort of a field
recording setup
i may also have
an iphone
with a
lightning
port connected
shore microphone they make some really
really cool smaller
microphones i can't remember the exact
model number
but i will have
redundancy
in person as well as backup options
remotely now i want to come back to one
thing
for those people who want to find this
episode we'll link to it in the show
notes obviously
for the
pro travel hacks episode number one of
all the hacks
i have another piece of feedback there
for you lee rowan is l-e-i-g-h
last name r-o-w-a-n
so two things i want to say
the the first piece of feedback is that
i would definitely transcribe all of
your episodes
and
read them yourself
in the beginning especially and look for
terms that you repeat a lot and try to
trim those down so for instance
as essential as the term is to the
namesake of the podcast all the hacks
i would suggest perhaps
dialing down on the volume of using the
word hack or hacks and thinking about it
like a magazine article if that word
came up over and over again the editor
would be like
here's thesaurus.com please come up with
some other words
so on the audio side i think it's very
similar and we all have these ticks we
all have texts and i remember actually
after the ed catmull episode oh this is
terrible
i looked on social to see what type of
feedback there might be
and i saw
many
tweets with
mmm dot dot mmm dot dot dot mmm dot dot
dot you're driving me [ __ ] crazy and
it turned out i was so nervous that
every time he said something interesting
about
like some
cave creature
and
it
it was just cringe-worthy to listen to
i had no awareness that i was doing it
and there are other words pet phrases
etc that in any given interview i might
repeat way too many times so
keep an eye out for that the other way
that i used transcripts early on and one
of your questions for me has been
how have you honed your your
interviewing skills
right do you ask friends mentors to
listen to episodes and give feedback
do you re-listen to your own episodes
okay let me answer those specifically
and then i'll come back to how i use the
transcript do i re-listen to my own
episodes no i don't i read the
transcripts
because it is
more painfully obvious what you need to
change
you can get away with things in
conversation
that
work and can work really well there's no
one
good style of interviewing or one great
style of conversation there are many
many ways to do this and many ways to
play this game so i don't think it makes
any sense for everyone to emulate one
particular interviewer or style of
interviewing
however reading the transcript
will make you
acutely aware of any repetition verbal
ticks things like that so i do not
listen to them
unless i'm checking audio quality which
i used to do of course but
these days i have a team to help
with that and by team i need i mean a
contracted
post-production
sound engineer
this is not i do not have uh i have two
full-time employees for everything that
i do in my life just to give people an
idea of how small my team is
do i ask friends or mentors to listen
sometimes i do
but in the beginning
if i did that and this is true with
asking friends for
feedback on writing as well i don't
think it's very high yield very helpful
and certainly i think it's quite
frustrating for the friends you're
asking for advice
if you just say give me feedback i don't
think that's specific enough
so in the case of writing what i would
do and still do
if i'm writing a book i split up
chapters which are intended to mostly be
self-sufficient they're kind of modular
in that way they're like feature
magazine articles the chapters
and i will send
say
a single chapter to
three or four friends ideally they are
writers or
lawyers or they've gone to law school
this is for writing although it's it it
can apply
to
audio as well
the reason for that is that both writers
and people who have reviewed documents
or learned to use a legal eye for
reviewing text
have a keen eye for ambiguity
they have a keen eye for anything
superfluous that you just do not need
that should be cut or can be cut
they're very very sharp observation with
respect to that so they make good proof
readers in my experience and i will say
among other things
please read this
and if anything is confusing
please
note that
you can love it you can hate it i'm fine
with either of those but if it's
confusing it's no good for anyone
so if anything's confusing please note
if your mind starts to wander
please note where that is
if your mind starts to wander means it's
dragging
right so i listened to a few of your
episodes there were a few points where i
started i was going on a hike like there
were points when i was totally immersed
in the audio and then there were points
where i'm like a squirrel
trees
a bird a butterfly which is fine because
i'm on a hike
but
your intention i assume is to captivate
me with the audio and there are points
where my mind started to wander so you
can ask someone to indicate like
if your mind starts to wander indicate
the time code
make sure you use the same application
for the time code because it can vary
from
application to application so if you're
using
overcast use overcast if it's pocket
cast use podcast spotify use spotify but
have have everyone use the same
app
okay in addition to that i will say if
you could only keep 20 if i were going
to cut 80 of this interview which 20
should i keep and would you cut it hold
on one second i'll get to that okay then
conversely and you don't have to use
both of these but i would say
if i had to cut 20
which 20 would i cut i actually like
that question more but i do
ask both for different reasons because
if if i give it to four people if one
person loves a section and three other
people say cut it i will keep it
if anyone loves something i keep it
that's my rule
but very often
i will
i wouldn't ask for feedback if i weren't
planning on
somehow using the feedback if i found it
valuable so the answer is yes i very
often make these cuts
but
asking your friends to listen to audio
and do this is really time consuming and
it's actually very hard for them to
specify things
so
what did i do with my transcripts one
thing i did
is i ended up reaching out and finding
someone who did research
and guest prep and everything for
inside the actors studio
and i asked them if they would be
willing to read
transcripts of some of my early episodes
and to indicate where they thought i
could improve what they think i should
cut
where they think the sequence might be
off in terms of questions
and that's what we did i would send them
word docs and they would add comments
and redline and so on you could
certainly use google docs or something
else i now use google docs for this type
of thing
but that that is how i improved
my
interviewing
and
interviewing just as a
as an aside but it's not really an aside
this is sort of a core piece of the
discussion
is like anything else right it's like
basketball like what makes a good
basketball player well which position
are they playing
right
what is the other team right if they're
boxers like styles make fights right
it's like okay
just because a beats b
and b beats c doesn't mean a is going to
beat c right i mean it really depends on
styles and
if you look at sales people what makes a
good salesperson well what are they
selling right some people are so
charismatic and have this reality
distortion field that people want to
befriend them and they'll buy from them
as a result of that some people are
super super technical
and kind of dispassion it in a way
and others are really good at deal
structure and figuring out conditional
purchase orders and kind of
navigating
the wants and needs of the other person
and being very very creative and how to
structure a purchase
maybe finance a purchase right these are
all different characteristics and
different skill sets
yet all of them
could be exceptionally good salespeople
right the same thing is true in
podcasting
right it's uh you know if you want to
grow your podcasts like
turn yourself into a super hot woman and
talk about blow jobs
uh i i've seen a few podcasts that have
done really well by uh by you know doing
that in addition to many other things
that you have to get right that is sort
of not necessary
but not sufficient i wouldn't say it's
necessary
but
you can't do that chris you could i
don't know maybe you'd find a market for
it but that's not going to work for you
if i tried to be joe rogan
with his
knack and talent and developed skill for
comedy it would fall flat
i'm not going to try to beat joe rogan
james lipton when he
ran inside the actors studio
never deviated from his questions he had
his list of questions
they were stacked in order on these blue
cards and he would never deviate even if
there was a side door to a topic that
could be more interesting he would not
take that side door now some people
might judge that harshly and say oh
that's stupid he should have taken the
side door
well
does anyone know your podcast
a lot of people know inside the actors
studio seems to have worked pretty well
maybe that format was exactly
what
he needed
then you have
folks who come in with meticulous notes
and i come in with lots and lots and
lots and lots of notes
that works for me
larry king came in blind
and larry king who also one could say
was early to the radio game in the same
way that some people early to the
podcast game so you have to
take that into consideration and maybe
discount things a little bit but he
would come in with beginners eyes to ask
the naive
questions that a listener might want to
ask he didn't want to know more than the
listener or the viewer
right so this is all to say
becoming a better interviewer is really
becoming your best self as an
interviewer
but no matter what reviewing transcripts
for me is a core piece of that
and collecting questions
i remember i would
effectively have not a three ring binder
but a collection of questions i would
take photographs of my phone
pre-cove it certainly if you're taking
flights it'd be the only time that i
read magazines
and you look at these in-flight
magazines they're always interviews
and if i found a good question
i would take a photograph and i would
test it
if i listened to a podcast and i
heard a good question i would note it
i've been interviewing people for hiring
for a new position recently and someone
i was interviewing i solicited questions
and they said
how do you give feedback could you give
me a few examples of when people have
disappointed you and how you've handled
that and i thought to myself holy [ __ ]
that's a good question
i might steal that one
so be a collector and a tester of
questions also
so i have a bunch i'm like going back
man i have a bunch of follow-ups here
yeah let's do it
backing up to the prep how long are you
spending you know let's go back to if
you were doing this all on your own
preparing for for an interview it
depends on the interview
but i would say generally minimum a few
hours
so let's just call it minimum
two to four hours
and i have some approaches for that that
i can share
and
maximum for instance
if there is a possible
big break interview
and one of those for me was arnold
schwarzenegger when that finally came
together
i spent probably four or five days
digesting everything about arnold
schwarzenegger i mean watching
interviews watching movies reading books
going through every past interview i
could find i wanted to be the best
prepared interviewer
he had ever met
and uh therefore i took it very very
seriously but if we're talking about
on the
average side let's just let's just
assume that's three to four hours now i
spend less time because i have help and
i have
cultivated a system and also improved
the system with the input of team
members
how to prepare
research
documents i would say
two to four hours i will also ask
guests to send
their favorite two to three long form
interviews
i will ask them
and not all guests are keen to do this
but some are very keen
for exploratory
topics or questions that they think
could be
fun for
us and the audience
and anything else that they would like
to send so i open that door and all of
those things are received typically
weeks or months in advance because the
editorial calendar is built out
quite far in advance
at least these days it is
if you're doing
prep from scratch
if the person has a wikipedia page i
look for the strangest or most esoteric
slash tiny
unusual mention in wikipedia and i do a
deep dive on that point
and i go into these citations
i will
certainly look at social this is
important because for instance in
between the time that you book a guest
and you record they could have a family
member die they could have any number of
things happen they could have some type
of disaster in the press you want to be
aware of what is going on so i don't
spend a lot of time on social but i will
check in
and go back at least a month or two
to ensure that i have a basic
understanding of what is on their minds
and hearts
that doesn't take very long i would say
that's less than
less than 30 minutes
so you have wikipedia and then long form
interviews so i will look at print
i will start
print meaning text long form
text interviews i will look at the
interviews that they've sent
and that helps me in a number of
different ways
it shows me where they're good it shows
me where they stall out or don't have
answers
it also helps me to gather what i
consider
greatest hits stories
and
here's what i mean by that
we all have stories
that we have told more than once
just like comedians who have worked on
their material and refined over and over
again that 60 minute special we all have
stories
that over time we have determined
get a great response
[Music]
and i want to know what those are and
sometimes i'll ask them point blank
either in prep or
while we're doing the warm-up in the
beginning i'll say hey is there a story
that i can cue i don't want to hear the
story now but a story that's really
funny or that always gets a response
from audiences maybe you've done a lot
of speaking engagements it's something
that people always come up to you and
mention
is there any story or anecdote or
metaphor could be anything parable that
comes to mind and
oftentimes they'll say
let me think about that yeah there is
okay ask me about the time that x ask me
about when i was in college and why
happened great
i will plant one of those greatest hit
stories within the first 10 minutes
if i have one of those
to pull people in
and hopefully pass the the driveway test
as uh
i heard someone from npr
put it which is when and this happens
with podcasts too
when you're listening to it in the car
and you've got 10 or 20 minutes left and
you get home and you just have to finish
it so you stay in the car in the
driveway and you listen to the end
i think it's it's helpful to plan that
through so those are a few of the ways
that i do research if we have any common
friends
or acquaintances i will also ask them
for topics and questions
they think might be
fun or that might take us
on the road less traveled
and i used to do this more than i do now
but i will sometimes post it to social
and ask what types of questions people
would love me to ask
given the size of my audience on social
now that makes less and less sense
because it's very hard to filter
very hard to gather them i will
sometimes do that but not not terribly
often
have you ever
done so much research
that you kind of knew the entire
conversation you would have in advance
because you'd learned you know you'd
read someone's book you learned all this
information it's like coming in arnold
schwarzenegger so prepared you know
there are probably things that you
wanted to talk about that you knew the
answers to
but how did that go because now it's not
as engaging because you know the answers
yeah i will always
leave lots of virgin territory
so
i will have some familiarity
not with all guests but some with
greatest hit stories so i'll plant a few
of those
but generally speaking my interviews are
going to be at least 90 minutes that
will be maximum 5 to 20 minutes of the
conversation
there may also be things
that they've talked about but there's
some aspect that was left out and i'll
ask about that
so
my
rule or one of the fundamental
precepts of how i approach podcasting is
if it's interesting to you it will be
interesting to other people
you can't [ __ ] fake it people can
smell it out it's like dogs can smell
fear audiences know when you are when
you are stoked and audiences know when
you're faking it so you gotta make the
interviews interesting for yourself
even if it gets into some really strange
topics that are going to appeal to a
very small percentage of your audience
doesn't matter you gotta include it
and you can always cut it out later but
you got to make it interesting for
yourself so in the case of
schwarzenegger yes
i had consumed vast quantities
of
interviews and footage and
commentary and so on related to arnold
but
he has decades of
time on this planet and there's a lot
that is not covered so is easy for me to
weave in
questions that would take us
to
unexplored
areas that was very very easy i'll also
say
do not get too attached to your research
[Music]
in the sense that
90 minutes goes very very quickly i mean
we've been recording for more than 90
minutes now
90 minutes goes very quickly so if you
have
tons of research in front of you
pick
the five to seven questions you most
want to get answered
that is for 90 minutes
keep in mind because i want the freedom
and the slack to explore side doors
and we may end up scrapping all the
research that i've done and save it for
a round two which is something i do
quite a lot and then i'll circle the
things that we didn't get to with a
highlighter and put r2 on them take
photographs put it into evernote and
share that with my team and i'm like
this is what we'll use for a round two
don't be attached to finishing
all of your questions
and very often what i'll do to try to
limit the impulse to do that
is i will block an interview into
sections i don't do this always but
sometimes
to let a guest know what is coming i
will say for the first 30 minutes we're
going to bounce all over the place it's
going to be background
personal story etc and i always ask them
for
specifics and examples right high
concept abstract stuff bores the [ __ ]
out of audiences it bores the [ __ ] out
of me there can be some high concept
stuff but we need real examples real
details and so on if someone's not
willing to do that by the way i will i
will sometimes not publish the audio so
if they don't bring their a game if
they're not playing to win and really
doing the prep i don't feel obligated to
publish that happens very rarely but i'd
say
around
a dozen interviews i haven't published
like if they're not actually
trying if they're not
attempting to do what will appeal to the
audience i'm not going to publish
are you direct with them and you're
telling them why you didn't publish or
sometimes sometimes sometimes yeah
sometimes you just lose the audio
yeah exactly i mean i wish i could tell
you that i'm always 100 honest about
that but sometimes especially in the
early days i was
not
confident or comfortable enough to do
that so there was a lot of audio that
just vanished into the cloud hard to
explain yeah but it happens
and and sometimes out there would be a
make good on that so let's say they have
an excellent book
but the interview was
just terrible
then
i might offer to take an excerpt from
the book from a particularly good
chapter put it on the blog and then use
that as a way to assist in some fashion
one of the questions that you had
and don't lose track of your follow-up
questions but one of the questions you
had is do i read the books
these days no and in fact i get sent and
have been sent there's a point where i
was getting sent like 50 plus books a
week
from publishers
by the way never signed up for these
lists never asked for them so if any
publishers are listening
please take me off your lists i'm going
to start putting specific names on the
sort of public hall of shame for
spamming me with
physical books you're killing trees
you're you're you're causing
the decline of our earth unnecessarily
with books that i'm just going to give
away stop it
stop it stop doing it take me off your
lists
but the point is i was getting 50 plus
books a week and that's just uh
untenable i can't even the books from
friends
or acquaintances if you consider the
hundreds of people i've had on the
podcast and the many people that i know
and have met over the years
it's imp physically impossible for me to
read these books and i don't want to
have to pick and choose so i actually
put up
people can see it at tim.blog
new books it is the the one decision
that removes a thousand decisions
there's a blog post about that and one
of the policies is i will not read the
books beforehand i'm only reading old
books meaning books that have not been
published in this year
so i don't do that however you can ask
the publicist or the author to send you
some some high level concepts
or
a one or two pager if they're using that
for interviews
and so on you can have them do that but
i do not read books in advance there
have been cases where i've read the book
in preparation like
in arnold schwarzenegger's case
or if
the authors are authors i've followed
for a long time like walter isaacson for
instance who's written incredible
biographies of benjamin franklin and da
vinci and so on
then i will read the books but it's
quite rare
especially in the last two years but in
the beginning
yes look you gotta you gotta earn
uh you gotta you gotta really earn
the quality of the output
in your interviews and if reading is
gonna help then do it because in the
beginning you're not going to be getting
sent 50 books
a week you may have slack in the system
to do that
what other questions or topics
in the beginning
did you ever you know as i've even found
myself as your interview skills get
better and better it's easier and easier
but in the beginning did you ever just
take a pause in an interview and say
let me just take a minute to really like
regroup and replan where this is going
to go maybe you don't tell them exactly
why
but what kind of things might we have
found on the the chopping floor
i will always tell people in advance
that
they should feel free to take a water
break or a bathroom break
and that they can also restate anything
so if they get two sentences into a
story and they're like ass isn't that
good i want to start over they can they
can just say that
you know let me just start that over
take two seconds of silence start over
and we can clean it up that also gives
me the ability and i'll say this i may
need a water break or a bathroom break
that gives me the ability if i need a
breather water bathroom or just to clear
my head and figure out where is this
going
where do i want to take this then i'll
do that
but my
episodes are
generally speaking minimally edited
very minimally edited although the
number of ticks
will determine how much editing
it is it is incredible
how many smart people have
atrocious verbal tics
they will say like like like like like
literally
a hundred plus times in a 90-minute
interview i i do not exaggerate or
someone will say
you know you know what i'm saying
you know
uh which which is uh which is actually a
very i've noticed some uh gender
patterns
i know it's very unfashionable to talk
about such things but
men
the you know you know tends to be more
of a male thing across the board
and
like
a lot of men say like but it's it's
especially noticeable
uh for a lot of women a lot of female
guests
it's kind of interesting that the the
ticks seem to to skew uh in in in
different genders in different
directions
ah those are all very common
there was one guest i'm not gonna name
him by name although i think he'd find
it funny he said he said he said he had
a really good one he he said and whatnot
and he'd be like
and what not
and what not and he said it so often
and at the time i just didn't want to
deal with having to edit it so i left it
in
and he went into the office
the day after the podcast had come out
and all his co-workers started calling
him mr whatnot
and uh you will
absolutely notice that so i
want my guests to sound as good as
possible if they're nervous i will tell
them that like my job is to make you
sound as good as possible
if you're
nervous put that on me
it is my responsibility as the
interviewer to
direct and shape and prompt in the best
way possible just be yourself
take any nerves and just put it on me
it's all on me so i will also say that
if people are nervous
uh
so that'd be a good example uh dot dot
dot if you do it once or twice it's fine
and you can leave it in but if you hear
that at the beginning of every answer
then it's a problem
another tick would be
that's a good question that's a good
question oh that's a good question
that's a great question oh that's a good
question you might hear that literally
20 times in one interview
you gotta clip that
they just won't sound
as good as they should otherwise and
that's part of your responsibility
yeah but if you're just getting started
there's a product that i've used called
the script descript is great or
description i don't know
yeah and it makes it really easy to find
these filler words i still find it needs
some tweaking around the edges because
you know they're not perfect but
it's a great tool for like running
through a transcript that that's
auto-generated but certainly cheaper
than if you were paying someone to you
know word-for-word transcribe everything
absolutely
and
looking at another question that you
sent me because to lay out how this
podcast came to be
you sent me a bunch of very good
questions via email which i requested
after we had an initial conversation
and one of them
which i then asked
to answer in this format so i could
point people to it is you seem to
understand your audience well how did
you build that understanding did you
survey them
ask for email feedback or something else
okay
i'll give you the tactical answer and
then i'm going to give you the principle
behind
most of my thinking
i have surveyed my audience but i
haven't done that at length in many many
years the reason i surveyed my audience
also was to gather
demographic data
average household income and many other
things
so that i could present that to
sponsors because at the time i had
dozens of sponsors coming in and i could
not answer those questions
now with
facebook analytics assuming you are
present on multiple platforms or your
podcast is present on multiple platforms
you have many different ways that you
can gather this data now
so
facebook would be one
there are many other options i did
survey
but i would say the way i've gotten to
know my audience is
this and this is going to be a very
unsatisfying answer fortunately i think
there's a satisfying principle that
comes after it
is
over
more than a decade since four hour work
week came out 2007 i started the blog i
want to say in 2005 or 2006
i have been
growing and learning alongside my
audience for
13 plus years now
and
you really get to know
your audience and your audience will
change over time so since launching the
podcast i would say my audience my my
readership
was
80
20 80 male 20 female
let's just keep it simple i know
there that gender is a sensitive topic
and there are more options but let's
just keep it
keep it basic for now
i would say
as of a few years ago it's more 60 40
female male
and i have changed over time somewhat
but blog social
blog meaning blog comments
social media feedback these are all
things that i pay some attention to
but that can quickly get overwhelming so
i would suggest that
people listen to i'll give you the
upshot in a moment but listen to my
interview with tim urban who has an
incredible blog called wait but why
and if he had followed any of the advice
for how to create a popular blog by the
way he would not have done what he did i
mean some of his pieces i want to say
are
thirty thousand fifty thousand words i
mean they're books some of his
multi-part blog posts are effectively
books they're long not all of them are
long one of my favorites is the tail end
it's not germane to what we're talking
about with the tail end just search the
tail end by tim urban everyone should
read it it will improve your life it
will improve how you relate to your
family it's a must read it'll take you
10 minutes
but he has talked and i think he also
talked about this in tribe mentors about
writing for his audience and he said
it's really easy and i'm paraphrasing
here but basically he imagines a huge
stadium
and
each seat is filled
by another tim urban
it's an entire stadium filled of
himself
and
he is just
writing
what he would want to read
and it sounds so simplistic
it sounds almost ridiculous
and
as simplistic as it might be it is it is
if it if it is
incredibly simplistic it is
incredibly effective as well
so if you know yourself
and you pay attention to what excites
you you pay attention to your fears you
pay attention to the goals that you have
you pay attention to things that you
struggle with even though you've tried
to fix them before you pay attention to
the things that bother you
you at least have a guaranteed market of
one a lot of people [ __ ] that up they
start speculating and you know they're
like a 22 year old
guy and they're like you know what i i
i went to
wharton and i figured out doing all
these financial models and management
consulting there's this huge opportunity
for
new moms who need
blah blah blah blah blah blah for their
kids and you know regenerative blah blah
they don't know anything about any of
these things but they've identified a
huge
market opportunity and that is
where they're going to focus their
energies for building a company that can
work i'm not saying it can't work in
terms of good financial outcomes are
they gonna have a lot of fun doing it
probably not
in the world of podcasting in the world
of writing
don't assume you are someone of
superhuman empathy and that you can
guess what other people need just focus
on yourself
and the personal will end up being the
most universal if that makes sense i'll
give you an example
this might screw up the audio for a
second
but
i'm holding up
an airpods case all right
now who else has an earpods case my
girlfriend
and
we mix up cases all the time
and
it's a huge pain in the ass because
sometimes i'll pick up what i think are
mine
they're hers
and
the the earbuds aren't even in the case
they're upstairs somewhere and then i
get to a coffee shop where i'm supposed
to work or do something and i can't take
a phone call and this problem has
repeated itself over and over and over
again i tried to
say use a sharpie to write a name on the
outside anyone who has tried that knows
that it immediately gets rubbed off
doesn't work
so
the solution that i figured out is you
open the case and you just put your
initials inside the divots at the very
top
right so you can see t
there at the top never gets worn off
works every time and we have not mixed
up
our aeropods since right
this is the first time i'm talking about
that but i suspect i'm not the only
person who has had this problem right
there is a piece of blue masking tape on
my wife's airpods case
which does not fall off like marker yeah
so you could do that as well you could
do that as well you could use masking
tape i mean there are multiple solutions
here this is the one that worked for us
great right
where to next
so
the audience thing is interesting i know
you're someone who likes stats and and
analyzing the data there is some
interesting data that i'm not sure if it
even makes sense to do anything with
so
you've got your downloads per episode
you've got these charts that apple and
spotify give you of like how where do
people drop off in a episode do you look
at that data do you do anything with it
do you completely ignore it
i do pay attention to downloads not a
lot of attention like i i haven't looked
at my stats in weeks
but if an episode does unusually well if
it's several standard deviations say
away from other episodes and there isn't
an easy explanation for it right so if i
have
lebron james on the podcast as an
example which i did then if that episode
is a runaway hit
i'm not going to be that surprised
because
some of what was featured in the episode
is picked up by espn and different
comments are quoted all over the place
so there's a lot of carry
but if there's an outlier that isn't
easily explained
then i want to
take a close look at that
if there's an underperformer that isn't
easily explained i also want to take a
close look at that
determining any causality whatsoever is
really difficult
unless there is a technical problem so
very often if there is an underperformer
the first thing that we look for are
technical problems
was there an issue
with any of the major platforms
and
that is important to keep an eye on
but
i have not found
i have not found the vast majority of
data that is easy to collect
or to find to be that actionable but i'd
be curious to hear your perspective
because things have changed and the
tools have become better
but still
i think it is
it is tempting to
conclude causality with say an n of one
with one episode that does something
strange and it's very very
hard with any conviction for me to say
that that's going to be an accurate read
yeah i have not found anything super
effective to use with kind of the
standard platform analytics
you know they're every now and then i'm
like wow that episode did a little
better i haven't seen any order of
magnet or like you know major order of
magnitude changes you know there's been
this one's 10 up 10 down i i kind of
attribute that to all kinds of
randomness yeah the one thing that i
will say
maybe this falls under analytics and
it's a another tip from kevin rose was
charitable is a platform that you can
kind of use for lots of analytics things
but the one thing they do that's really
cool
is if you put their prefix in front of
your feed which means every episode just
gets hosted on a platform you can tell
your hosting platform hey make sure the
url includes this other thing also so
that someone else sees whenever that's
requested
and so you can create a link
so you know if this were on my show
would be link.chartable.com
athtim
and
then chartable will say what ip address
went to the link
and then look for whether that ip
address actually requested an episode
and so you can go and say here's a link
to promote an episode you could give it
to you you could put it on different
social channels you could give it to a
guest if they want to promote it and you
could see which channels are actually
converting to downloads which i think is
something that it's always easy to see
who clicked what but did they actually
listen to the episode now you can't find
out how many minutes they listen to or
anything like that but it's at least one
piece of evidence to support what to do
and i used it to make a decision which
was interesting when you are promoting
an episode you basically have two
choices you can send a link to every
platform out there which some people do
they go on twitter and they're like
check out my new episode here it is on
itunes and here it is on google and here
it is on spotify and here it is here
here here or you can link to a site that
like your own website where it's click
here and now there's like seven player
buttons where the you know the
individual listener could jump off to
or
chartable will let you say if someone
opens out an iphone just directly take
them to the podcast app which is great
if they use that it's probably a
terrible experience if they're a spotify
or an overcast listener so i actually
tested out one episode i did one way one
i did the other way one i did the next
way and i just looked at which one of
those links converted better and the
best conversion was sending them to
my website with the player links on it
then trying to guess or listing multiple
things and
what success is depends on how you
define success and what metrics
constitute success for you right so
one could be increasing downloads
another
could be
increasing plays which is a lot trickier
although different platforms
count
downloads and plays differently right so
you might have automatic downloads in
the background
on apple things may have changed but at
least a few years ago that was the case
and that would count as a download even
if it were never touched never seen by
the person who owns that iphone
versus say on spotify if someone clicks
play that counts and then people might
look at their analytics and conclude oh
spotify is only five percent of my
downloads and quotation marks
therefore i really don't need to pay
attention to it whereas in reality maybe
it's 20 or 30 or more of your actual
plays
so it's important to understand the
limitations and the
mechanics of of some of these platforms
i would also say an additional benefit
of sending people to your website is
that you can
offer or incentivize
them to sign up for something like a
newsletter
because as it stands
if you are publishing through an rss
feed in the way that most people do
you do not have a direct relationship
or i should say you don't have the
ability to communicate effectively
directly with
the people who listen to your podcast
and i view that as a problem in the same
way that i view
any
business based on a single platform as
highly vulnerable i remember talking to
somebody who had it it was something i i
don't know 10 million a year business
built on
a facebook page of some type facebook
pages and i and i asked them
how that was going for them and they
said well it's going great but it feels
like i have the most profitable
mcdonald's in the world built on top of
an active volcano
any moment at any moment
the algorithm could be changed
suddenly oh you're a business page okay
now we're gonna throttle your organic
reach to like 10 of your audience and
you're gonna have to pay to reach
the people you thought were guaranteed
to see your message
i don't like that i don't like that risk
and
therefore for me at least
one of the
core
drivers for
using the newsletter
as i have you know five bullet fridays
is the most popular aspect of the
newsletter which is free so listeners
you can find that at tim dot blog such
friday i've been doing that for a long
time now
is to
establish
a direct line of communication with my
listeners and readers and quite frankly
also because text is
my native language
right everything started with books and
so in the same way that that rogan is
really really really really good on
video he's also quite clever via text i
mean i think his his there are many good
reasons why he is incredibly popular on
instagram i mean some of his some of his
captions and so on are
exceptional and they're long some of
them
for me that translates to feeling very
comfortable very competent very good
about the newsletter writing five bullet
friday is therapeutic for me and so it
is in a way a diary and self therapy
and
quote unquote marketing all-in-one
which is great
so
those are a few thoughts
but i don't pay
a lot of attention
to data but i will look at trend lines
over time
and if there's some type of catalyzing
event or concern
especially due to technical problems or
new policies on platforms then i'll take
a quick look at that but the fact of the
matter is
i wouldn't pay too much attention to
data or specific data sets until you've
asked yourself
what action
will i take or not take or what
behavioral will change based on looking
at this data set
and if the answer is none and none do
something else
unless you're just it nurtures your soul
and kind of
tickles your nuts to
chew on data if that's just your fun
that's your recreation great have fun
but otherwise i wouldn't pay too much
attention to it
so one of the the most common things i
think people look at data for and it's
not clear like you said that they would
do anything about it
is
to try to see if their audience is
growing yep so i know you said don't
don't think about growth but we can come
back to growth i think one of the
interesting things is a lot of people
have podcasts good content
and you know i've been asked to go on
some podcasts where they get 100 200
downloads an episode and they're just
not not breaking out but it's not
because they don't have good content
you obviously came into this i remember
you said that when you launched your
podcast it was the number one podcast in
itunes yup i know i know i know you get
a boost when you launch
but not everyone has that do you think
other than good content
is growth something you think people
should spend any time on
because you know people have to find
that good content sure i think i think
growth i think
awareness is perfectly valid to focus on
and i do pay attention to growth right
i i do track
i'm very well aware of like the average
number of downloads at week two at week
six per episode and
total number of downloads and
i do pay attention to a handful of key
metrics
i just
don't
i don't pay attention to them
to the extent that they become a
distraction from things that i think are
more important
but in the beginning for sure i i
launched like i said 2014 and the
ecosystem has exploded since
competition is
i mean probably a million x what it was
i mean at least a few thousand x what it
was
uh although i would say just just
because there are a lot of podcasts
doesn't mean automatically that you have
competition
competition for what what is the scarce
resource that you are competing for
if not why is it a competition is it an
ego thing what is the competition i
think these are questions worth asking
but to come back to growth so when i
launched in 2014 i should also say
there were people who said to me
that ship has sailed it's too late
there's no point doing a podcast
in 2014 so
i think they were wrong then and the
people who say that now i also think are
wrong
it's still very very early
think about it i
mean amazon has only come into this
space in a big way very recently and
they're very quietly i suspect doing
lots of interesting things but they have
not thrown
all their weight behind this
and they have a lot of weight to throw
that is just that is just one example we
are so early still i think
but with respect to
what has helped
increase downloads
i would say
being on other podcasts first and
foremost
helped drive subscribers
you need to be explicit about asking
people to go to the podcast and being
explicit with the host that that is why
you are coming on the podcast
otherwise i don't think there's
automatically a high conversion rate
people who listen to podcasts probably
listen to more than one podcast
so i i do think that there is a fair
amount of transference when you're on
other podcasts
and it makes you a better podcaster to
be on other well-run podcasts
so you can take notes on process how
they prep you what technology they use
what did they do or not do that you
could adapt or not adapt what are you
doing that you might want to discard so
there is an educational part also to
being on other podcasts that you might
not get from pursuing growth through
other channels
i think that
newsletters
are also very powerful email and
newsletters they're powerful for
everything because they are one link
click away from whatever the desired
action is
so those would be two
that come to mind
and
there are other ways to increase
downloads and subscribers
certainly big names don't hurt
but
it's one thing to get somebody to your
podcast it's another to have them stick
around and be an active listener
so
if you get a celebrity on and they are
mediocre at best is someone going to
listen to a second episode
i would guess not
they might have an automatic download
but what is it that you actually care
about the download number or the number
of active listeners i care about the
number of active listeners for a lot of
reasons
hard to
confirm what the active listenership is
but big names definitely help right the
arnold schwarzenegger episode and the
amount of promotion that i then did
behind it
right so i do use
paid acquisition advertising things of
this type
having
a
name to
really put a lot of the machine behind
and muscle behind
which could be as simple as a basic
campaign on your platform of choice that
doesn't necessitate having a blog and so
on like i do
i think that is that is certainly
helpful
but it's it's a temptation that needs to
be tempered because you could spend all
your time chasing big names and i think
it's a fool's errand as i mentioned
earlier
uh certainly video
i think
youtube tick tock to some extent
certainly although i think andrew chan
has written
some very interesting pieces about tik
tok and its effects on virality and some
perhaps unintended or unknown
consequences
of sudden influx so people can can
google that and find it
youtube can be extremely helpful and
i've seen that with many podcasts now
it's it's not just limited to joe rogan
you have
many examples i mean jordan peterson
would be another example there are
probably thousands of examples but i
could certainly think of it a dozen
offhand who use video very very well
those are a few
and pr
pr if you want to practice your chops
with getting out in other types of media
outside of
podcasting
then knock yourself out you could do
that as well
when you said video i noticed you have
two kinds of podcast videos on your
youtube channel you've got the
static image of the cover art and the
guest and just playing the audio and
then the actual interview
are both of those effective or do you
really think the the real boost comes
when you have video content the real
boost comes from video content for sure
yeah the static images are placeholders
from audio only interviews
so to put them on youtube
we choose
a
cover page of some type
and that is what people see but for sure
actual video
moving
images
makes the biggest difference and i will
say you know that i i i suspect a lot of
people are going to be very disappointed
with my answers on growth here and
i will say and this is such an old man
thing to say but i'll say it anyway
there is no magic bullet
for growth
and the tools change so
i would suggest
getting a book like the 22 immutable
laws of marketing
reading a short chapter called the law
of category i believe i put an updated
slash edited version of that in either
tools of titans or tribe mentors because
i think it's that valuable
read the law of category
read 1000 true fans by kevin kelly which
you can find on kk.org
these will give you
principles adaptable principles that
will allow you to build a unique
position
in the minds of people who will become
die hard evangelists
if you do that
which takes consistency over time and it
takes focus more than anything else
a lot of the other dominoes will tip
over
without any additional effort
but
if instead of learning how to draw as an
analogy you're focused on whether you
should use a ballpoint pen or a fountain
pen or pastels or crayons or watercolors
meaning
the
the different technologies and tools
clubhouse versus tick tock versus
instagram versus oh vine remember that
oops
uh oh
if your promotional engine was based on
that uh oh
facebook business pages oh
yeah you're gonna need to boost to reach
your audience now sorry about that
there's too much fragility in
a tactics or tools based approach so i
think the principles are most important
but
i recognize also that perhaps i am just
too far
from the nascent
years in which i built my blog following
to provide a good answer i will say
though that i built a very very very
very popular blog when
practically no one knew who the hell i
was
and i did that by writing posts that i
hoped
10
of my then very small audience would
love
i did not write posts that i wanted a
hundred percent of my audience to like
and i do the same thing with podcasting
i think it works really well so i do not
expect my entire audience to love any
episode and if i tried to do that i
think i would shoot myself on the foot i
expect that my active audience will be
in a rotation in every
fourth or fifth or maybe tenth episode
they will love so much that they will
send it to ten of their friends that is
how i think about it and i i believe at
least so far it has been extremely
extremely effective
one of the pieces of feedback someone
gave me on my show was that
not every episode is relevant to them
right i did an episode where i
interviewed a professional car buyer
and they were like i don't have a car so
this episode's pointless they're like
maybe you should
change the show
so that everything's always relevant to
everyone and my answer was i don't know
i'm gonna buy a car i wanted to talk to
someone that professionally does this
and that's super interesting to me so
you know just skip it and go to the next
one
do you feel similarly you said you know
one in five to ten people love that
episode do you care or or do you think
they're listening to the other five to
nine episodes
i don't care
i i literally spend zero time thinking
about it because
and this this might sound strange but
for me to be
for me to have fun
for this to be a
joyful experience that i look forward to
the podcast needs to have a certain
essence
a certain poll for me
and it has to have a certain dosage
so i have a very infrequent podcast i do
it
on average four
times per month or i publish four long
form episodes per month we didn't really
talk about recording cadence which we
could talk about
but on average i published four
long-form interviews per month at one
point it was six episodes
and then i noticed a few months into
doing that
i was starting to drag my feet
a little bit
and
it began to feel like a job like an
obligation and i noted that quickly
thankfully and i said this is no good
if i keep this up i'm gonna stop doing
the
podcast or i'm just going to be unhappy
doing it in which case what the [ __ ] am
i doing because i don't need to do it
and i then ratcheted back the frequency
of the podcast to the point where it
felt good
so it's there's a dosage question
i.e frequency there's also an essence
poll question so for me i have to follow
my own interest and to be of
a good steward of my own self-care but
to also be of greatest service to the
people who are listening i need to keep
doing this or
at least i hope to keep doing it maybe i
don't need to but i would like to keep
doing this and to be able to
grow over time and share those lessons
the only way i'm going to do that is if
i
am drawn to continue doing this because
i enjoy it so
if i decide to do an episode with a
violin appraiser and it gets 10
listeners i don't [ __ ] care at all as
long as i enjoy the episode i do not
care and i will say that over time
that not caring is the ultimate form of
caring because you can
cultivate an audience who is interested
in stepping into weird strange corners
of the world
into interests and professions and lives
that they perhaps otherwise would have
ignored or avoided
so your audience will also change in how
they relate to you
over time
and at least in my experience
they i hope
have realized that sometimes it is the
episode they least would have expected
to want to listen to that they end up
liking the most
of perhaps
the last 20 episodes i've done so i
think my listeners are more and more
willing to give me the benefit of the
doubt and try something strange
i got some feedback from joe saul cehai
who who runs a podcast called stacking
benjamins which is a funny like kind of
different style podcast but he said
the interesting thing you have to
realize with guests is someone might
listen to the episode for the guest but
at the end of the day they're
subscribing and coming back for you
and so the nature of interviews though
often is
you know we're trying to highlight the
gaston and hear their stories
which inherently if done well is them
talking more than you
you mentioned earlier if it's a bad
guess it might be you talking much more
than them
how have you
how do you make sure you interject
enough of tim into the podcast that new
listeners and recurring listeners get
that
when the focus of each episode is is
always on someone else
that is a really good question and the
answer is i don't
think about it at all
but
there are some times when i will
interject and it has a strategic purpose
or a practical purpose
there are interviews where i basically
don't talk at all
and if someone is just
you know a woman or a man possessed and
they are in flow i will let them riff
it'll just be an audio book of that
person
for an hour or two hours
uh you can listen to
tim ferriss and uh
biology that's an example of that
the four hour
every topic under the sun covered
podcast which was
quite quite an experience to be on the
receiving end of also great episode
very unusual and one of the best
performing podcasts probably of the last
year for me which is saying a lot so if
people look up my name or just go to
tim.blog and search bology b-a-l-a-j-i
yeah put in a mouth guard and drink a
few cups of coffee and prepare yourself
for the onslaught it's quite something
but
i will interject in a few instances
one is
where i know i'm asking a question or i
suspect i'm asking a question the guest
is going to have trouble answering
unless they have
some time to think about it
so
for instance if i ask them
what is one of the best investments
you've ever made
which by the way is better than what's
the best investment you've ever made in
the same way that what is one of the
books you have gifted the most for other
people is better than what's the best
book you've ever read
if you the search function is a lot
harder it's going to take them much
longer to try to come up with a single
answer
and they will generally default to
recency they'll come up with something
that happened recent so you don't get
the best answers
if i ask someone
for instance what is one of the best
investments you've ever made and then i
might
buy them time
by giving some examples i'll say let me
give you a few examples and give you a
second to think about it it could be an
investment of money like so and so
say warren buffett who invested in dale
carnegie's speaking classes for public
speaking and he always cites that as his
best ever investment because it has
multiplied and
magnified his ability to do
everything else
it has been a supercharger for all of
his other skills and talents
it could be
buying an entrance ticket to a
competition that allowed you to prove
yourself that
then led to
x it could be an investment of energy it
could be anything
okay i just gave everyone listening and
you
45 to 60 seconds to think about an
answer
as opposed to off the cuff coming up
with something as quickly as possible
fortunately
you can take that approach or if you're
not recording live
you can just say take your time
we're not recording this live you can
take 30 seconds in science to think
about it
and then
we can talk but that feels strange to a
lot of people even though
you can do that from a production
standpoint
sitting in a conversation in silence
waiting for a minute for someone to
answer feels unnatural and weird
so i will interject
in a case like that
very frequently when i speak up it is to
buy time for the interviewee and to give
them a few examples
to act as like auxiliary search
functions in their own brains so they
can come up with the best possible
answer
i you know i was thinking the whole time
about my my best investment
well what is one of your best
investments
well it's funny when i moved out to the
bay area i didn't know anyone and so
and i had recently been laid off and so
i didn't have any money but i invested
in a membership at the climbing gym down
the street
and at the time i thought this is you
know it's not the climbing gyms are not
cheap gyms there's cheaper gyms but
through the climbing gym i met a guy
named daniel burka yeah who was at digg
through daniel i met kevin through kevin
it's like it's literally probably the
investment that ended up building out my
entire network uh including being here
but at the time it seemed you know it
was like 120 bucks a month it seemed
crazy but that's amazing was that
mission cliffs or where were you it was
mission cliffs yeah yeah it's a great
gym i remember mission cliffs back back
in the day
so that's a fun question to ask if i ask
someone about favorite failures
just the phrasing of the question is
very confusing for a lot of people so
then i'll give them an example
right yeah
and
the other time that i'll chime in is if
if the interview is drowning in boredom
[Laughter]
as a rescue attempt
what else do you have
so i want to talk a little bit about the
transition early early tim was really
just the four hour guy
right you had three books in a row where
that was the theme
someone told me once they said hey you
know your cover art for an episode of
podcasts everything nothing has anything
about you on it so i i took a similar
early on approach where the
this story of the show is all about what
the show's about all the hacks it's not
about me at all and people are like well
who are you and you made a transition
now your podcast is you know the tim
ferriss show it's it's nothing to do
with four hour i i get the sense that
you're trying to run away from being the
four hour guy
but how have you thought about that
transition and and making it
and making a brand that is really about
you
instead of
something else
i'm gonna tackle this from
uh oblique
angle
and
i'll couch it under the umbrella of
identity diversification
and
also optionality so
flashing back to the four-hour workweek
four-hour workweek was this huge
unexpected hit
that stayed on the new york times list
for four to five years straight every
week
and
it created an abundance of inbound
opportunity
almost all the requests
were
expectedly related to the four-hour
workweek so i was the four-hour workweek
guy we want you to give a talk on the
principles of the four-hour work week
appointment to do consulting to help us
improve efficiency and
per hour yield within this organization
we want you to do this workshop we want
you to
license the name so we can develop a b c
d e we want to option it for
a movie which is almost always a dead
end by the way if people are wondering
we want to talk to you about a musical
we want to do this we want to do that
most of those things
all came to zero
but
all of the
external pressures
were to
milk that for everything that it was
worth in other words
i would write the four hour work week
volume two or i would write the three
hour work week i would
continue to beat that drum until
i had shaggy gray eyebrows and
could bang the drum no more right that
was going to be me and i saw many
authors
around me who i met on the speaking
circuit early on when i did that i i no
longer and for many years have done no
paid speaking
which was a categorical decision and
policy that was one of those decisions
that removes a thousand decisions
for many reasons we could talk about
the short answer is i was repeating
myself
and when you repeat yourself this is
this is relevant to my point
when you repeat the same messages
as as my friend josh waits can point out
to me you begin to calcify your thinking
and you're also repeating it because
you are being paid for this perishable
product which is speaking to
audiences over and over again about the
same thing
and
i recognized i did not want to be many
of the people i met who had been milking
the same thing for a very long time they
didn't seem particularly happy about it
they didn't seem energized by it they
seemed drained
and they
seemed to feel trapped to me which is
why
given the success of the book i decided
to maintain preserve the
the brand recognition of four hour but
move it into physical performance with
the four hour body because i recognized
i might never have this chance again
to step out to have license to go to a
completely different section of the
bookstore completely different subject
matter
but i could always go back to the
four-hour workweek so i could always
return to that comfortable
familiar
well-worn path of these principles
outlined in the four-hour work week so
this is this is i think an important
part of the back story
so i decided to go to
for our body for our body does extremely
well for our body hits number one new
york times
still sells extremely well
and
that then bought me the license to write
the four-hour chef where i'm taking
these principles which also come up in
your podcast fair amount with andy
ratcliffe recently
of wealthfront the 80 20 principle
so pareto's law
and many different
principles that you could apply to
deconstructing entrepreneurship and
testing assumptions apply equally to
physical performance they apply
equally to accelerated learning language
acquisition cooking doesn't matter
so now i had
proven to the people who pay me at least
up front the publishers and also
proven to my audience that what was
interesting
was the adventures and the principles
not any specific subject matter it's
hard for me to overstate how important
that is
i was no longer trapped in one section
of the bookstore i could write about
anything i wanted right now i had
license to do that
okay
the four-hour chef
almost killed me it was it was it was an
incredibly complex extremely difficult
project it was the first major
acquisition by amazon publishing when
they were really stepping into
publishing in a big way the entire
publishing world freaked out barnes and
noble wouldn't carry the book i mean it
was
it was exciting and also a huge mess on
many levels
and
each book launch
i would talk to best best-selling
authors
who had launched in the preceding say 12
months and i would ask them which
channels tools and outlets
did less than they expected or were
waning in importance and impact
and which did more than they expected
and seemed to be in
in ascent
so for the four-hour work week
blogs
were neglected largely i mean blogs were
incredibly powerful neglected that's
where i focused with the
for our body i asked the same questions
and i explored a bunch of different
channels
for the four hour chef
the
the medium and the tool the channel that
was most undervalued but most impactful
was podcasting
so i focused on podcasting for the
launch of the four-hour chef and these
podcasts had incredible impact
much more impact than
huge television shows
and
in the process of doing that i really
realized how much i enjoyed the long
form conversations where you could be
yourself you could drop an f-bomb if
need be or if if that was your your
penchant or just speaking casually and
comfortably
first is say being on morning television
which
can have some impact but seem to have
less and less of an impact where
someone is staring over your shoulder at
a teleprompter and you literally have 30
seconds to talk
after spending like an hour waiting in
the green room after having your your
your face spray painted with makeup and
you woke up at 5am to get there it's not
that enjoyable an experience
so i saw the impact i enjoyed the
podcasting and decided then at that
point i'm going to take a big break from
books not sure i'm ever going to write
another book
but in the meantime i'd like to
experiment with this podcasting format
and see what it's like to be in the the
director's seat so to speak
and
the only reason the podcast ended up
with the tim ferriss show is the name is
i couldn't come up with a name and kevin
called it tim tim talk talk in the first
episode which long-term listeners still
joke about and i still joke kevin and i
still joke about
but came up with all of these different
names for it and
the fact of the matter was at that time
there were only two things
that had a lot of brand recognition the
four hour shtick which i didn't want to
extend
i wanted to retire that jersey
or my name and
that is the reason
that i decided to use the name but if
you're just starting a podcast and you
don't have any name recognition
i don't think that the logic
automatically follows that you should
use your name
now it it's been a wonderful trip i will
say that there are
drawbacks to
launching a podcast with your name in
the same way that there are drawbacks to
founding a company that can only be run
by you
as we've seen in the news there are a
lot of
big deals by podcast standards
happening at the moment there is a land
grab for talent and big shows and
audience so you have joe rogan
purportedly 100 million dollar deal i
actually think if i had to guess i don't
know this but i would suspect it is
substantially larger than that over time
with earn outs and so on
and performance bonuses i would guess
it's much larger than that i think there
was
somewhere between 60 and 100 million
deal for dax
shepard
something like a 60 million dollar deal
for
call her daddy i think that's a
three-year deal you will notice that the
deal terms appear to be getting
more and more onerous
now those are not all comparable deals
those are different people different
properties and so on but i believe as
part of the deal with call her daddy
that spotify has a first look or writer
first refusal or automatic ownership of
future properties and creations not just
current
joe rogan has a licensing deal
which is very different from an ip
purchase agreement
but this is all to say
that
if i had
let's just say
who knows the four hour podcast
if i called it the four hour podcast and
i owned that trademark
and slowly brought in
other hosts or co-hosts to help
one could foresee an option of building
that up into a property
with
many different personalities and selling
that property
after which
i as the initial
builder of that brand could be free and
clear to go on and do other things
it is not
possible to do that simply with a
podcast called the tim ferriss show
yes so there are drawbacks
but net net that's the story of how i
got there and i don't think about
building a personal brand to be to be
clear you have a personal brand
already everyone has a personal brand
guess what your personal brand is your
personal brand is what your closest
friends and family and co-workers think
of you that's it what do they associate
you with right if they had to pull four
or five adjectives out of the air how
would they describe you whatever comes
to mind
most naturally when people think about
you that is your personal brand so we
all already have a personal brand if you
want to create a personal
facade
or a stage persona i'm not saying you
chris but just in general you can do
that but you should be very careful of
that
and
i remember
i was
told and i'm paraphrasing here but by
andrew zimmern
who is an amazing television host
who is very smart and very very
thoughtful
who's been on the podcast his story is
incredible i mean he was i think
sleeping on a mattress
under an overpass at one point as an
addict and now is who he is it's a
really remarkable story but
when he was just getting started in
television and he and i spoke when i was
doing some television not too long ago
he had some choices to make in that
first episode
about who he wanted to be and how did he
want to deliver his lines were they
going to incorporate any particular
types of shticks
were they going to be
funny were they going to make fun of
certain things were they going to use
the cheesy jokes
and
he made a lot of decisions early on that
ended up being critical to the future of
his career because he said
in effect be very careful of who you are
in episode one because that's who you
have to be for the rest of the time
you're on television
and i think that's true podcasting so be
really careful about what you pretend to
be
because you will have to maintain that
and you may actually become whatever you
pretend to be so i don't
i don't think a whole lot about personal
brand
although i do think about what i want to
stand for
and
if i were really true to myself like if
i were really true to myself what would
i do who would i interview if i were
just doing this for me
what would i do and
i always get the best results when i do
that when i try to predict the movement
of
the masses of some potential audience
like this
you know flock of birds where i'm trying
to guess which direction they're going
to fly it never turns out well
for me especially it's not fun and it's
not particularly effective
one of the things you mentioned in that
that story was about these podcasts
getting these acquisitions you know
licensing deals or different things a
common thing that i know happens with
podcasts especially as they start to
gain traction and has happened to me in
the last couple weeks is
some podcast network will reach out and
say hey do you want to join our network
do you want to be an i heart radio
podcast and usually get to keep all your
ip but you know they basically say hey
we'll sell ads we'll keep 50 we'll help
you grow your show we'll do all this
stuff you don't have to think about it
we'll just give you the money we make
and and it seems to your point about
monetization like don't spend any time
on it spend time honing your craft spend
time making a good show
is that a good
way to kind of take all of that off your
plate from thinking about it would you
encourage people to take those calls
because they don't result in having to
spend time selling ads though you lose
you know upside for whatever term that
deal is
this is this is a this is a worthwhile
topic to explore so clearly
or maybe it's not clear but i i do not
work with a network or a partner of that
type a lot of people do
a lot of people do and
i think it depends a lot on what you
are
trying to accomplish
right so a question everyone should ask
is three years from now your podcast is
successful what does that mean to you
what does it look like exactly like what
is
what is a month
in your life look like with respect to
the podcast
it's successful what does that mean
what does it look like
so depends on that it also depends on
your competencies your willingness to
hire or work with
contractors or commissioned sales people
to sell ads
or sponsorships or find sponsors if that
is something that you want to do
is it worthwhile to take the calls it's
always worthwhile to take the calls just
don't promise anything yeah definitely
take the calls and the question that i
would ask myself in preparation for
those calls is how can i learn as much
as possible from this cost that if even
if i never end up talking to this person
again
i get a lot out of this
right can you ask about best practices
of other podcasts can you ask about
common mistakes
that highly competent but novice or new
to the game podcasters make in their
experience
can you ask them
as a policy when you have these types of
conversations you always ask if i
couldn't work with you
who would you recommend i work with can
you start to get a better understanding
of the ecosystem
can you
ask them about other players in the
system and
in other words
further your education
and give yourself more and more of an
informational advantage
even if you never do a deal with these
people
if you're willing to prepare in that way
come up with good questions
absolutely take the call if you're gonna
if you're just going to
fly off the cuff and
see what happens
maybe it's still worth taking the call
although you won't get as much out of it
but yes it's absolutely worth taking the
call
and
and listening to their value proposition
there are a number of different ways
that you can sell ads
you can
you can publish on a platform that
inserts ads
automatically and there are platforms i
believe spotify has this ability there
are platforms that can do this
there are also hosting companies
i believe that will use dynamic ad
insertion to fill out inventory for you
your
revenue from that your income from that
your cpm right the cost per thousand
downloads you get paid will be quite low
for that generally speaking
you can work with a network
and that network may have people
in-house
but
the network could be a network just like
you and i back in the day could print a
business card which is like chris and
associates
and in fact all they're doing is
partnering with yet another company
and then they're splitting the
commission or the vig
between them so that's another thing
that you would want to
ask although i would ask it at the end
of the conversation in case it pisses
them off
are these full-time employees of yours
do you partner with other companies do
you subcontract out pieces of this to
get to get an idea of how things are
architected
so you could partner with a network
and
if they say we will help grow your show
i would find out exactly how they do
that
gimlet of course
does a good job of this as do many of
the npr shows because they cross promote
new shows on existing properties
if they're going to do that find out
what the reach is
find out if that's going to be for all
geographies or is it going to be a
geo-limited is it time limited blah blah
blah all the specifics right that's
probably for a second conversation it's
not that important
compared to other questions you could
ask all right so that's that's a network
you could work with
companies who
sell ads
that's it that's all they do they're not
a network but they will
they will
put sponsors in front of you and put
your show in front of sponsors and there
are
many many different agencies that do
this
just like ad agencies for other types of
media
and the economics will look slightly
different depending on who you talk to
and they'll be different probably from
the networks
then there are very very small shops
with maybe a handful of people
and they handle ads for larger shows so
i will not mention them by name just
because i don't want them to get deluged
but if you're diligent you can figure it
out
joe rogan dax this american life all
work with the same small outfit
who only work with a handful of premium
properties
and they sell ads for those outlets
then you can have a contractor or hire
someone full time as i did
to handle all of your ad inventory
i am comfortable as an operator i'm very
very very very comfortable with sales
and i'm very very comfortable with
waiting until
in this case my podcast had enough of an
audience and not just a large
audience in terms of size but a powerful
audience in terms of influence
such that i would be able to say
no very easily and still have takers
does that make sense and then to set
terms
like no payment terms you need to pay up
front so that we can keep
our process extremely extremely simple
and uh in that case i looked at it and i
was like okay
let's just take
i mean you can do some back of the
napkin stuff but it's like all right if
i won't use joe as an example i'll let
people try to figure that out on their
own but for him to do a deal of several
years at 100 million dollars that would
have to be a multiple of what he was
making
he was making i am sure a lot
right but let's say that you get to the
point where you are making a small
fraction of that and you make a million
dollars in total ad revenue
which
assuming you don't have much staff is
almost pure profit
if you outsource your ad sales
i would say you should expect
generally that at least 30 of that is
going to go away
okay
so i'm no mathematician
but
that is more than three hundred thousand
dollars so then the question is
for less than three hundred thousand
dollars
could you hire someone who is absolutely
excellent
to do it for you and our this is just as
critical
are you willing to have staff manage
do the calls do the data analytics and
so on everything necessary
to ensure that those operations are
extremely smooth the answer for a lot of
people is no even if you have the money
they would rather
spend the
300 000 dollars plus in this case
now keep in mind you know if you're
making 10 million a year
then now we're talking 3 million plus
right
it can be very very expensive
but it's worth it for a lot of people
for me i decided i had enough
entrepreneurial experience
i am comfortable enough with operations
and process and management
that i am
totally happy to
hire someone full-time to handle that
for me so that is what i decided
that makes sense
okay so we've hit a lot of things we
have
here's a great question about a question
which is
if you're interviewing someone about a
topic and you realize well past the
point that you've talked about something
that there's a great follow-up but
you're now
you know three turns down on a different
highway
do you
ask it still
and if you do
do you try to edit it back so it fits or
do you just save it for next time
i've done all the above
so if we're down this road and there's
something i really want to ask
you have
many many options for me one option
would be you write down on a piece of
paper this is why i like to have notes i
take a lot of notes as i'm writing on
things that i want to come back to also
or things that i want to ensure i don't
forget
so i'll take that i'll circle it on a
piece of paper and i'll say
if you don't mind i want to interrupt
for just a second this is going to be a
complete left turn
and for all my listeners sorry that's
just how my mind works i really
want to just put a bookmark in this so
please remember where you are i'm going
to write it down i want to ask you about
x
and then we're going to come back to
y and z and so you can do that
you could take a note of it and then
use a teaser at the end of the episode
and say we could easily keep talking for
many hours
we might have to do a round two if you'd
be open to it
and simply circle that in highlighter r2
like i do and there are different ways
to approach this
and save for next time
you could also try to edit and splice
somewhere else
and kind of franken clip your way into
some type of narrative
that tends to be or can be very clumsy
and labor-intensive so i i tend not to
do that
well then i'll just throw it out here
because it's uh it's about a guests
one of the things i found i i heard you
say that you got a lot of guests by
asking people hey you are a guest are
there other interesting people i should
have on this show
in recruiting i've learned that when you
go to people and say hey are there
interesting engineers i should hire
everyone has nothing they have to use
that search function but if you go look
at their linkedin and say hey here are
four people that you know that i think
could be good for this job
if you think any of them are would you
introduce me to them that works well
is there a tactic you've used to find
guests from your network of either
friends or guests that helps them kind
of jog the memory
to find the people that might be
interesting
no
this is a short answer i don't have any
particular tricks here i
will mention to people i'll say i really
enjoyed speaking with you you're
excellent at what you do and
this was outstanding if you ever think
of anybody who you think
would really enjoy being on the show who
i would also really enjoy speaking to
please let me know
and i just leave it at that i would say
at this point
probably 80 plus of my guests come as
referrals from past guests
wow
and
it will become easier and easier over
time right when you have 15 episodes
it's harder it's just a smaller sample
size when you have
30 50 there is a non-linear
kind of growth
in the connectivity of the map that
you're creating this constellation of
guests
and the types of people they can reach
so
it gets i would say exponentially easier
over time to get
referrals and
i will also say just as a side note
a
question that you can ask to also
improve your
interviewing and podcasting
is one that adam grant asked me when he
was a guest on the podcast
after we stopped recording
and you need to be insistent
but he said
or he asked rather
what can i do to improve
and i i gave him some throwaway answer
because it's an uncomfortable question
so i said something like it was great it
was really fantastic and it was he was
really really really good and he's and
i'm pretty sure he responded with
i appreciate that
i appreciate the kind feedback and i'm
not gonna let you go
until you give me one thing just one
thing anything could be small that i
could
do to improve as a guest
and i think he had a habit of
uh
i don't want to say nervous but
laughing a lot after certain questions
or answers and i said
that might be something that you could
take a look at if it was
one thing and i had to pick one thing
you were outstanding it was
absolutely
wonderful as is but if i had to pick one
thing that would probably be it he was
like awesome great thank you so much and
he was stoked
if you want to get that type of feedback
you have to be insistent i think because
it's uncomfortable you're putting
someone in an uncomfortable position
right after you've done this thing
you're feeling good probably to deliver
news that you might not like and so you
have to just say look i love this stuff
i'm not going to let you go just give
you one thing could be anything tiny
things something that i could do
to improve
and that gets results
and that is my dog barking because i
have a delivery coming to the door so i
think we should probably wrap up in a
few minutes since we're almost at three
hours but
i know you have prepared more and so who
knows maybe there is a round two
in our future but
what other
boxes do you think we should check
i have a good kind of
wrap-up question at least is
you launched your show and you said
you'd commit to six episodes and i've
seen you say
you'd reassess then and then after
deciding to continue i saw you say you'd
reassess again at a hundred
what
kind of a process do you go through when
you reassess is it just a gut do i want
to keep going or
was there more going on each time you
hit that milestone
it's a pretty simple check-in right it's
like how do you feel
i think most things can be boiled down
to how do you feel when you first wake
up
and how easily do you go to sleep
like how do different decisions affect
that
certainly true in investing big time
right like you could have on paper the
best investment of all time but if if if
you're waking up anxious and having
trouble going to sleep it's probably not
a good investment for you
and this is true for podcasting too what
do you how do you feel when you look at
your calendar and you see that you have
a podcast at 10 a.m or 2 p.m or whenever
it is right like what happens internally
is it a whole body yes
i mean how do you feel mentally how do
you feel kind of in your chest how do
you feel
in your gut and and really paying
attention to that
it's a full body check-in
for me right imagine okay
it's tuesday you're tired
and
all you want to do is call it quits but
you realize you've got
to 90-120 minutes ahead of you for a
podcast
how do you feel what do you do what is
your self-talk what does it look like
what has it been those are the types of
questions
that i
ask myself
and
i want podcasting to be something
that nourishes me and refills me not
something that depletes me
and
i think many if not most of my decisions
these days
with respect
to just about anything
are framed in that way
and
it's simple but the implications are
pretty far-reaching
so it has nothing to do with revenue has
nothing to do with how big the names are
it's really
how do i feel when i see it on the
calendar
how do i feel
when i'm recording how do i feel when it
comes out
is it net positive energy or net
negative energy
and if it's net positive
yeah keep feeding the dragon
that's how i feel
and also you can build in the ability to
take breaks so for instance to touch on
one thing that i
dropped a long time ago which was
recording cadence and by the way your
brain is really incredibly trainable you
get better at doing this as you record
more and more podcasts just like
mentally bookmarking things to come back
to
recording cadence so i will very often
once per quarter do a content creation
week
which includes
all of any social needs
and all of my podcast needs for the next
three months and i will record all of
them
in
perhaps
one week monday to friday
or i may tag on an extra monday tuesday
and the following week and i will record
all which for me means 12
say episodes
for the next three months and then if i
want to do more episodes if i feel
compelled if there are things that pop
up like this episode for instance i
don't need to record this episode we're
recording this
early september i have all of my
episodes until probably december covered
already they're done i don't have to do
a damn thing i can't sit back and chill
but
i wanted to record this episode because
i get so many questions about podcasts
and i also want to answer your questions
so you can
batch
recording in that way
i batch any sponsor recording
in a similar way so that i'm
not doing by the way like refreshes
people who want a live read every time
not gonna do it i'm like if you have an
ad that is working do you keep using it
until it stops working in terms of your
sort of return on invested capital right
your multiple or
whatever it might be
and their answer is oh we keep using
them like that's exactly what we do so
once we have a good read we keep using
it and
[Music]
for that reason i'll batch recording for
sponsors in a similar way
and
any review of guests with
one person on my team we will
know more than once a week for a very
short period of time maybe five or ten
minutes
review potential guests who have come in
typically from past guests and decide
how i feel about them doesn't matter how
interesting they are how good they are
what they do
at the end of the day like zero to ten
no seven allowed what's my stoke level
if it's not eight nine or ten
we do not press go
and
that is also
some of how i systematize the production
and the editing and so on such that
the tasks and the responsibilities of
the podcast are not
scattered
kind of willy-nilly all over my calendar
which is very
would-be i think stressful and
ultimately a net negative
energetically so batching also helps to
make things much more fun
much easier much more streamlined and
much less expensive and ultimately
coming back to the very beginning
much more sustainable
and
for all of those reasons and more
i don't have a set time to check in
with myself about the podcast
i batch
and
i expect if you check in with me five
years from now unless something really
strange has happened i'll probably still
be doing the podcast
but was the batching always there or you
know you only committed to six episodes
at the gate
that means in episode seven you needed
to find in those first six episodes of
production how long did it take to get
to that batching versus
just in time like i need to go set up an
interview so that i can release an
episode next week
well the batching is as needed so their
batching has some practical utility in
the sense that you
finish everything in one week as
necessary for the next two to three
months but i also get energized by the
podcast so i will sometimes decide you
know what i'm not going to
batch all of my recording but i'm going
to do one recording per week or every
other week because i find that it
refills my tank
so it's not a burden to be lightened it
is also something that gives me more
fuel for everything else that i'm doing
therefore i'm not going to record
everything in the batching session but i
will record enough so that i don't feel
like i have a gun against my head and oh
[ __ ]
it's
tuesday and i need to put out an episode
on thursday [ __ ] now i need to rejig my
whole schedule
that's not an experience i want to have
and it's one that i can very easily
avoid so the batching and the
systematizing comes in my experience
later you got to throw a lot against the
wall and figure out what works and what
works for you
and then you can establish policies and
rules so that you're making very few
decisions
instead of
a death by a million paper cuts yeah and
i do think that striving for
what excites you
and striving for what nourishes you goes
a really long way
and to come back to a couple of
recommendations the 22 immutable laws of
marketing the law of category read that
chapter even if the examples are
outdated read it get the older copy
not the for the internet because i think
the for the internet was written like 98
or 99 and the examples are really funny
but get the older version positioning by
the same authors
rhys r-i-e-s
not eric but
an older reese and trout i believe are
the names as well as 1000 true fans by
kevin kelly kk.org kevin kelly honestly
may be the the real life most
interesting man in the world and if you
want proof of that you can listen to my
first podcast episode with him
stuart brand might be uh
also a close contender i think kevin
would probably say stuart brand is the
one who wins that title
but it's a fun game i encourage everyone
to try it
you'll learn a lot about yourself at the
very least
so
yeah i definitely have
and
with that my friend
i think
we can bring this to a close we will
link to everything in the show notes
all these various things we've talked
about including the article the very
very extensive article i wrote in 2016.
and the link to the podcast with rolf
potts will link to all of those things
and more
in the show notes
but
i don't want to admit one very important
thing and that is
to mention chris's podcast and
we didn't get to go into lessons from
different guests which i asked you to
prepare so maybe another time we'll do
that but i've listened to a couple of
episodes uh really enjoyed the
i listened to your first and your last
so at least on overcast i listened to
the first episode which was with lee
rowan which was outstanding really
enjoyed it even though i'm not
hugely obsessed with points and
optimizing on that side there were a lot
of really good points so i'm gonna go
refer to the show notes on that and i
listened to andy radcliffe who's
incredible one of the co-founders of
benchmark capital also which is one of
the most successful venture capital
firms of all time i think their initial
fund i learned this from the podcast had
what 92 x returns it's just bananas
and that's that's an episode on
investing as you might imagine
and i'm listening currently to
episode six on the psychology of money
with morgan hausell and enjoying that
quite a lot so the podcast is good it's
super solid and i think you're off to
the races man i don't have
tons of critical feedback for you i
think you're doing a good job and it's
really about keeping it interesting for
you and staying the course but what else
would you like to say
about your podcast and where people can
find it
i would just say give it a listen and
wherever you listen podcast which you're
obviously doing right now so just search
for all the hacks
and reach out if you have feedback and
there's topics you want me to explore
all the hacks.com is that right yep all
the hacks.com
allthehacks.com and this man knows of
what he speaks
chris is
optimizer supreme and i don't say that
lightly it's it's kind of mind-boggling
to me how methodical you are with
optimizing so many areas of your life so
this is a a person who walks the walk
and i've seen it firsthand
in many many areas so i encourage people
to check it out allthehacks.com we'll
link to it in the show notes
and it is good to spend time with you
christopher yeah thank you for
co-hosting
hosting this episode
yeah i can now i guess i can put on my
resume host of the tim ferris show you
said it had to be you but here we go
tim tim chris chris volume two
thanks for tuning in everybody
you